this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
well good afternoon everybody once again
and welcome aboard on the sunset Safari
my name is Ralph Kirsten and on the
bushwalk camera this afternoon I've got
Craig with me how's it Craig and hi to
all of you please don't forget to join
us on the hashtag Safari live on Twitter
and on the YouTube live chat send us
your questions and your comments and get
involved in the largest game drive slash
bush walk in the world now this
afternoon I've decided to come out and
just try and follow up a little bit from
this morning's bush walk everybody seem
to be finding quite a lot of lipid
tracks moving around Galago pen looks
like these two female lipids in the area
another Tandy was on the dam cam and
around five o'clock this morning but
nobody was able to find him this morning
on the drive on the walk so we thought
that will come out we'll see how they've
moved around and and and just you know
see you or what has transpired now I've
got the other guys out steve is on
vehicle and so is Rafiki dave and so
we've got a lovely team on the move and
i'm sure that between us we'll be able
to find something exciting so I'm I'm
gonna just be looking for those checks
and looking for anything else exciting
along the the check we've got our noses
to our to the ground and so one of my
other team members Rafiki dave i'm sure
he's ready to say hello hello everyone
and a very good afternoon my name is
always David and his meet you in the
camera is fog hiding fog very good very
excited to have you oh no sunset to
drive and we are ready to head out what
I wanted today is to help my brother off
in finding out these elusive Lipper days
since morning
and since the day before yesterday again
sorry the trucks are being seen but they
are not leading to her so where she is
nobody knows for a fact and all of us
are not very sure what is du Loup Oh
Tandy well if it's tiny maybe you could
be seeing Tandy and the princess Columba
so we haven't seen two sets of trucks
have just been one but for all those who
saw those trucks they're saying it must
have been a female so what I want to do
is to work very close with bushwalk team
with ruff and hobby and see whether we
gonna smoke out this lepidus that has
been quite elusive since yesterday
the times javi said he could even smell
it you know he was so close to it but
they could not see it so we're gonna go
straight on to us their buffer shock
water our hole and that got the left
back to the west area where we think she
is this morning there's a very clear
loud buck and one of the girls in the
final control code blue she came and
found me by the carpark checking the car
and she went like David did you hear
that back did you hear that back and she
goes the torch like it must be here it
must be here that was quite interesting
but Tony a while this animals you will
see the cuts from a long long way well
even they give the back it couldn't be
like half a kilometre away or maybe 300
odd meters but they could very good eyes
very good remember on the drive is very
interactive your questions your comments
are more than welcome and this represent
one called Steve would be more happy to
wave and say jumbo to all of you
Jambo Jambo I love everybody welcome to
my section of the game Drive my name is
Steve Aldrich I'm joined on camera this
afternoon bus ends or the three-finger
damn geezer and yes indeed as David said
it is a very interactive Safari and we
are looking and looking and looking this
morning we were sent on a wild goose
chase but we reckon two leopards
definitely two we got a call from a
mechanic who seen a leopard we were
charging into that area and then we
found the tracks of what seemed to
almost be a male in the sand but it
should do lose tracks cuz there are
bigger in Tandy's tan he's got a very
delicate little than Queens sort of
track but you do lose just she's a
bigger leopard and that's why initially
I thought maybe it's a male but on
second look it's not a male it's just
splayed in the sand and bigger than the
tracks we were following but what is
going on with those two we don't know
but there we go Ralph has taken up the
challenge this afternoon and David it's
got to give him some help so I'm going
to go to add the parts of Juma that I
haven't seen in the last couple days
because my leopard tracking has kept me
this morning very close to Juma or to
Gallager lodge and yesterday the lion
tracking kept me all the way in the West
so we're gonna go check as we always do
now water points the watering holes see
what animals are in and around there's a
little bit of a breeze it's not very
strong but it's coming from sort of the
south south east ish sort of side and
let's see if I just stop and we get a
look in the feel of the wind obviously
now that I'm in this little depression
the wind is completely stopped as a bird
and the five distance flying there might
still be vultures headed towards bovis
look damn it's a gentle breeze coming
from the south
I'd said pretty much from the south
right now and all its doing is drying
everything out I can tell you that for a
fact because a few of us went tinged
some running this afternoon a few hours
ago and it dried us out completely after
lap one I had no moisture left at all in
my mouth or nasal area but that drying
out is what's very characteristic of
this time of year there's no moisture in
the air and it's just blowing through
and just drying out the plants and if
you ever want to cure meats or cure wood
door you dry it by air drying that works
very very well sure you can get them
white Christelle the tracks there's
another one just down here on the log
since on the lift there we go
and they respond very very well to alarm
calls if you are watching the show you
this morning I'm still quite dry from my
rent and these are one of the birds that
were giving that out a very hard time
time there's enormous alarm calls
happening in these birds trying to
supplement their their diets at the
moment they can really move through the
trees there's having a little bit of her
oh it's caught something it's giving it
a bashing it against the branch can I
inch forward since Oh swallowed it we
just saw a kill ladies and gentlemen we
just saw a kill put a little insect
whatever it was got smashed against the
branch just to loosen it up and to
soften it inside maybe even break the
carapace that didn't quite see what it
was but very efficient hunters they move
through as a swarm and they just eat
whatever they can
so I was talking about the drying out so
that's what's happening now the plants
of drying drying drying but as we come
into these little depressions you'll
notice it's a lot greener on the trees
because there's still water down below
that's how we were able to live out in
these areas because we have figured out
how to tap water from bore holes to draw
for them
elephants know how to do it as well and
they often dig there's a little bit of a
a little bit of a spot over there I
don't think this was used but there's
some elephant dung in the middle of the
drawer of a bed and it's not uncommon
for elephants to to dig deep into sand
especially in dry riverbeds around
corners and to access the water this is
just a very simple example but we do
have other other ones that are a little
bit more prevalent and they're able to
sand filter the water preferring
sometimes water out of dry riverbeds to
water in water holes because what
happens in the water holes well hippos
live in their Terrapins and fish all
sorts of organic material gets passed
through their bodies the elephants have
a little bit more of a taste for sweet
sand filtered water and david is off to
seemingly is a favorite watering hole
yes and I'm heading there
and as usual holes will always be
showing some good life but before
getting there we found these two
antelopes here should be like a young
male and a female and I think this
danielís would you want me back up a
little bit okay hang on for a second
tell me when [ __ ] all right that's good
sorry about that honey put some Yanis
just saying good afternoon and moving
their ears they are slowly entrusting
for the last couple of weeks the wind
has been quite still but to this like
the wind is picking up if we look at
that water and the bush willow tree
there you can see the leaves how they
are moving the whip in water and that
Yala got ears opened and all out movie
one after the other wind always brings
them a bit of a confusion states not
really confusion but they tend to worry
about because of the amount of wind and
you can see how independently they can
move one year from the other so by
bringing them out and they can pick up
any sweetest sound and bearing in mind
it's windy it might affect the hearing
and to be slowed from eating men baying
browsers they got a lot of choice to eat
but it's time not wait and listen what
the wind is doing and then they can
continue eating pretty young me hello
guess we bought a year plus you can see
the panting of the ears because of the
heat of the day 80 or so degrees
Fahrenheit is pretty hot under tend to
breathe a little bit fast to cool off
all right excellent we'll be moving
forward now as you leave Daniela's to
listen to the wind and hopefully nothing
gonna happen to them it let's find out
where the Steve got a smaller kind of
all with him now yes we found the
smallest standard as a youngster toss
mongoose a little one all on his own
cell you decided to have a Dickies
initially looks a little bit too scared
bolted for a hole and then decided hang
on these people aren't gonna hurt me and
has now been ferreting around I've never
actually spent time with one like this
then ormally always running away this
one is a very brave how any walks you
see the shoulder blades normally they're
running all you see is their bottom as
they disappear were you lucky enough to
find them on their burrow as their groom
certainly acts is only about four or
five meters away from us at the moment
and if we look small to you on the
camera but he's noticeably smaller than
an adult which are normally about almost
like three quarters bigger than that or
twice as big half as big should I say
it's very very cute he's kind of baby
faces Lou the director yes yes opposed
it does if he can show himself behind
those little grasses there he's very
cute
you're gonna come a bit closer yeah it
comes I've honestly never seen one on
their own I don't know if maybe the rest
of the family is off and he's being a
little bit cheeky ferreting around the
bin you know as youngsters we'll do stay
home mums hid her right exactly the
angsty teenage fed the rebellious stage
where no one knows better than I do
oh here we go a little scratch nothing
like it here he comes
what did you catch very busy moving
along maybe after all sorts of insects
on the floor and so termites that might
be out any beetle grasshopper lizard if
they can catch it scorpions if they
could dig them off the ground
Oh sands he's too quick err you need to
have a need to be a sports photographer
cameraman she had to keep up with this
guy proper action I didn't think you'd
stick around for this long did you
looking up at the sky every now and
again as he moves but that would be
where the danger comes from definitely
from a raptor but that doesn't always
come from the sky sometimes they can
just be perched in a tree they can come
along Raptors concede extremely long
distances but Java it was just a little
hole right here that we first saw them
go for it's only about 2 3 meters from
the side of me there and you see it
sends just pass that in parlor done it's
just a little hole
let's jump off quickly and show you he's
not disappeared into the undergrowth but
here was the hole right there it's
possible that this is one of their many
little burrows in the ground maybe he
was just ferreting gone now into that
small little I love to talk about it but
there's a small branch on the floor
there that the grass is building up and
that's been damaged by an elephant and
that's creating the habitat and not just
for the Mongoose to go into but for
insects and all the sort of thing is
that he'll be looking for inside so very
very cool to find a little dwarf
Mongoose like that if we're gonna go and
it seems that Ralph has found a tasty
treat that this little guy would rather
enjoy
well the mongoose would love some
termites but so with these ents that
have obviously started riding this
termite colony and if you look closely
you can actually see some of these ants
pulling these termites of parts in the
teching from all fronts it looks like
mostly soldier termites and it obviously
would be soldier ants as well but
difficult to see with a very small
answer is the odd much bigger headed
ends as well but there is a lot going on
here and this is just near to some
elephant dung and well these are some of
the only arthropods that are active
during this time of the year there are
there are a few others but mainly the
two months and the ants they'll continue
on through the winter months as well now
that's that elephant dung that we are
talking about just below a tea I think
the termites have made this the home and
the ants are now riding looking for
their pupae and all sorts you know we do
get Mata belay ends as well
now Conrad and FCU say this reminds you
of the the movie ants
yeah absolutely Amaya my kids often
watch that show and it definitely does
and that the and also the end bully
where the little boy well the boy gets
shrunken to the size of ants and then he
obviously learns the lesson that he
needs to be careful of of sort of
killing little insects and that because
if he's that size you might land up in a
similar situation but many of them and
is so much going on there it is a
complete war I would say Tiffany I don't
think there's enough ends to what at the
entire to my colony they would however
make a big dent in the population but
the termites will breed again and so I'm
sure these ants will be taking quite a
bit of them for the protein and they
might also take some of the pupae larvae
or there are the eggs as well so they
might be going right down into the the
base of this colony you know we also get
mutter billy ants but they're more
nomadic and they raid much bigger ends
then these little reddish ones reddish
black and they they move around a very
black and they move around and attack
big termite colonies and they known for
that I haven't seen much of these little
ones attacking these too much so it's
quite fascinating but awesome to watch a
you see what I mean as we looking for
leopards we just stopped along the route
and look for all sorts of other things
so we just keep kind of targets at the
end of the walk but we stopping going
through all these little drainage lines
looking for leopard Jack's finding all
sorts of things like this so the wars
between ants and termites sometimes with
these termites they can activate the
soldiers and they can defend themselves
quite well
Gary I think it's mostly the ants they
seemed to be winning this little war
they they they did seem to be a little
bit smaller but they're also more mobile
and it seems the little pencils or they
are they biting apparatus it's quite a
bit quicker than the too much they don't
seem to be able to defend themselves as
well and I think the exoskeleton is a
little bit harder than the soft abdomen
of the termites termites quite
vulnerable if the the end can get it
from behind and then you see how it sort
of fences into that that abdomen and
then it's em and I start almost like
wild dogs pulling them in also all
different directions it's yeah it's like
there's a whole bunch of killing going
on here that is absolutely amazing so
these guys do very much like dry
conditions and they do very well in that
but it seems
Rafiki dive he likes or he's found
something that locks very wet conditions
crutch and Tom might support a low to a
way out in biome they're very important
because they support a lot of animal
stamens and without Thomas I don't know
how the ecosystem would be doing and
we've got some animals here that would
also love to eat a sombrero that who
knows who would love to eat some it and
we go summer Terrapins we've got a
moisture appeals and very initial to see
a fully grown on two or three young ones
of they're basking themselves or the
edge of the waterhole
two weeks ago I saw quite a bit number
there's a drummer they're just trying to
fish drummers are very funny buds
they're carnivores and drongos and
they'll take a chance to get any shrimp
and just jump in the water tube thank
you very much [ __ ] forgetting that
jungle and back with our therapies and
the drunk was back in the water again it
must be seen some interesting things
there and maybe the same animals or the
same organisms the
fed by this Terrapins so one of them has
gone back in the water always very
skittish I was saying I was here two
weeks ago and I think we saw about 50 of
them and the drunk would jumps in the
water again sometimes it might jump in
the water just to align their feathers
if not necessary because they will not
maybe it in the water like that they may
just yeah in and out and I think what
she could be doing there is just to
align her feathers and maybe to cool off
right drongos have been known to be
doing that a lot Sitting Bull how are
you today
thank you very much Lou then it's a bit
warm now is a bit for now we are doing
about 28 degrees Celsius and 82 degrees
Fahrenheit Sitting Bull that's those are
our temperatures today and I do not know
Sitting Bull from where you are or from
me home what temperatures do you got at
the moment if you could be happy to tell
me and more from the knot here we use
the center grid and not much Fahrenheit
so how easily say 20 degrees Celsius or
centigrade but because of Imperial
system will also give the temperatures
in Fahrenheit and it's 82 Sitting Bull
I'd be happy if you could tell me what
temperature's you got there so that's
drama basically I don't think he was
eating she was just jumping in the water
to align her feathers and you can see
now what she's doing
from whatever like how you go have a
shower that exact now what she is doing
sometimes they have even gone known who
else raining drone was to go out in the
rain not to feed specifically but just
to enjoy the showers and it helped them
to align their feathers you can see now
she's trying to maintain them and when
she was jumping in and out of the water
ideally she was not fitting my guess is
she was trying to dip her self and make
her sweat and by so doing is a lot easy
now to streamline
her feathers depends
on what you'd like how clever these
birds are huh
and when it comes to making alum calls
the drongos are very good but also just
like the monkey sometimes I found out
they're very cheeky cheeky but jumps in
the woods again
officer gum bucks the same spot yes
thank you for being so patient so it's
in the water
OOP very good and back the same place
and trying to make foie gras with his
lens but still fog is able to catch up
with her speed exactly and Lou inferno
control things he may be having a death
tonight
it's very possible I mean today's a
Sunday she might have gone to church in
the morning and maybe the civilly she
could be going for a drink that
somewhere because what he's doing is not
fitting she's just getting in the water
Thank You fog and dipping her feathers
there and making herself wet and what
she'll do is - we lost her not a problem
ah this yes very good and then she is
going to maintain oh ha feathers and
she'll be looking good and you know as
Lou says she will be having some
dead-straight maybe she could be a
female and she might be doing some you
know mating calls later and one the more
the male a pop-up will see some
beautiful good-looking female I'll just
saying earlier how sometimes in dramas
can be cheeky when they do alum calls
the very lab or but we have found them
sometimes or person I've seen them
during alum course and when all the
other bands will lose their
concentration and go where the drama is
this but if they're having for example a
party of eating something the drummer
will very quickly go to where they were
and start eating their food so she's got
two types of alan course one of them is
genuine and the other one is just bit
cheeky I have seen it a few times work
and like all the other birds you know
will get attention - ha ow - the drunker
finding out what could be the problem
and then she leads the less where they
live they're feeding party or whatever
they're feeding on and the drunk of all
quickly sneaks back and enjoys their
meal and you can see the tail there is
[ __ ] that's requiring the [ __ ]
drunk on 62 and 16 thank you very much
that you can see it's much warmer here
than where you are sitting would thank
you very much for the feedback this
quickly got to Steve and find out what a
bit he has for us right now yeah well we
found Zazu ladies and gentlemen and he's
been running around on the ground his
crime self a lizard was skink looks to
be a skink and I can't quite make out
which he's gone in looks like a oh no
can't quite tell what species it is he's
making short work of it definitely
killed it already and getting ready just
doing some tenderizing that went to move
his only his but his back more she's got
it back to us going to end up swallowing
that thing hole can you imagine there we
go that's a better view here comes the
money shot for sensitive viewers bear in
mind this animal is doing this live and
this is food see how it lost its tail
the tip of its tail in an attempt to
protect itself didn't work against the
hornbill he's going to probably try to
rip it apart until it becomes more
manageable pieces
was he going to swallow the entire thing
into the crop Oh
maybe it's going to go back to the nest
and you still see it just landed over
there somewhere can you see him since
there are s in the open decided to take
its meat to the shade and this could
take some time to break it into
manageable pieces or is he going to try
and there we go starting to rip you see
what the headers it's kind of breaking
apart
see that's why horn bells do so well
they varied diet and a strong long beak
allows them to to not migrate a lot of
the birds that we find sticking around
here have sort of adaptations meaning
they don't have to leave they can feed
on fruits when there are feed on insects
when they're at their highest and then
scrounge around and feed on things like
like lizards skinks Avex
even seen one feeding on a mouse before
shame anybody give my ID on that little
little lizard very indeed and the eyes
are bigger than the belly if it gets the
whole thing down I think it knows it
won't get it all down in one go so it's
going to try and and dismember it in
some way also keeping its eyes open
because it while it's going through the
stage it is potentially vulnerable like
that mongoose was there's no other
hornbills to be seen that i could see so
it's probably wide also moved into the
shade to get a little bit more less
visibility from a prying predator
remember the beaks off adaptations
should not allow the birds to lizard
smoothy says Lu ya is trying to break it
up so the beaks are just adaptations if
you can think about how much stuff we
can do with our hands the beak is the
be-all and end-all of the birds and
depending on the size shape of the beak
and strength of the beacon large birds
to to specialize in certain sort of
feeding tactics and strategies and quite
like almost like a the sushi chef with a
pair of tongs it's like you know David
does doesn't look tasty to you okay what
def he looks more tenderized than it did
when we first saw it looks like one of
those ornate ornate lizards Wynette's
and lizard I'm not sure it's hard to
tell with him moving around like that
anyone can get a screenshot off maybe we
can identify it playing with his food
indeed a wonder of his mom taught him
the manners don't play with your food
ours always told I suppose when it's as
big as that you need to try and figure
out how to make it a bit smaller Lee
says the horn ball doesn't look very
playful lizard I don't think is plain
dead I think it was dispatched right in
the beginning when we found it wouldn't
have taken too long the very strong beak
of the horn Bell
very agile like a pair of chopsticks I'm
moving it around
Lucan FC reckons maybe he's defrosting
it because it's come out of the freezer
here we go is it going down oh no I
thought that was gonna happen there this
is fantastic
this is his Sunday dinner now you can
see why the the shrikes while the Sharks
use thorns the Shrike will impale that
exact lizard and the track being a lot
smaller a number of shark species will
impale it on a thorn and then that
enables it to rip off pieces you can see
that because the Horned all flicks it
left and right it's not getting too much
sort of ripping power you know it needs
to be a little bit more physical almost
like a dog would be when a dog grabs it
sort of chew toy it rips it apart needs
a little bit more physicality to rip it
apart even that is being very physical
it's just not physical enough before the
lizard that's obviously the Skinner's a
little bit harder I once watched one
feeding on a mouse as I said and it was
just wiping the mouse and wiping the
mouse and wiping the mouse and
eventually we had to leave her just it
was a very long time that it took to to
eat it I don't know if it ever actually
ended up doing so definitely had it
though just like this I wonder if at
some stage it's just going to swallow
and I'm seen with kingfishers before
giant Kingfisher swallowing a an
enormous fish and the fish would come
out of the mouth still as its swallowed
and they would have to regurgitate it
and then ever it's smash it against the
branch for another 10 minutes and then
do the same thing before swallowing it
and it just didn't work so that's why
there's a food preference and a fruit
sort of prey size that certain birds
have because they don't really have the
ability to to tear things apart
unlike the rector species
which holds with their foot and can rip
it apart that enables them to eat meat
and prey that's much bigger than them
and then the shrikes which obviously
have evolved to to rip prey apart by
using a thorn there's all
specializations that have happened in
the animal kingdom and this Honda's
going to have to make do with the tools
it has today I don't think it has the
potential to put it underneath its foot
parrots able to lift food to their
mouths with their feet it's a very good
adaptation owls as well so that's all of
these sort of things birds to specialize
and you it's possible I mean it seems to
me as if it's trying to rip it apart so
that I can get a chunk at a time almost
like when the you're at a restaurant and
a steak arrives in an entire in this
case it should be the entire turkey
arrives at the dinner table and you are
told to eat it with your mouth and you
can't cut it at all with a knife and
fork very difficult to put that entire
thing they don't have the potential to
chew so this entire lizard or the parts
of the lizard are gonna have to go into
the crop there we go he got one of the
legs off there munch that down it's
gonna go into the crop which is
basically just the SEC underneath the
throat the gizzard while the crop and
that's where they can store food and
then the gizzard is a sec below that
before entering the stomach which is in
a lot of birds has mainly made up of a
few pebbles and stones it's a muscular
sort of sack and the stones inside there
with the muscular contractions grinds
down and break down whatever it is
that's gone in they don't have teeth
like we do and most of our mess most
about breaking up should I say happens
in the mouth or is in birds if they
don't rip it apart that happens inside
the crop or inside the gizzard itself
gizzard or the crop is a storage area
where they can keep stuff they can take
it all the way back to a nest or to a
partner
fantastic isn't it obviously certain
birds have got very strong digestive
juices so once the organism goes in
without being chewed that just gets
digested that comes out the other side
lots of uric acid would come out with it
bones and everything would be broken
down in the case of owls they are
actually often regurgitate pellets of
all the bones and the fur that didn't
quite go into the digestive system or
would not be digestible here we go he's
trying is he gonna give to go there he
goes are we watching get a screenshot of
that
oh he's struggling who else is getting
the gag reflex right now ah it's not
sure come on one more push his legs
still hanging out the mouth this is
crazy
he's in better clothes now oh I think
you might regurgitate it he's not
question go move it a bit okay
okay what you gonna do now you're gonna
whop your beak on something he's trying
to see oh he's trying to swallow look at
that and neither the beak her throat was
moving a bit okay now what really
struggling it was incredible what exit
stage left table set is now sitting in
the tree this is just above where he was
there we go
looking now I'd say wipe the beak off to
clean yourself that meal will stand that
young hornbill in good stead for a good
period of time antastic okay
very characteristic of birds after
feeding any type of feeding to go and
wipe their beak off on the branch and
that is the end of that
well everyone we are still working the
drainage lines and if you know I've had
a couple of questions regarding drainage
lines and this is exactly what a
drainage line is here in front of us and
we these you know all of them like the
name suggests that the water drains
towards the lowest area and then it
starts to wash down through there so
obviously down in there there's quite a
bit of erosion because the water being
washed down yeah then it all joins up
and starts to move down these particular
areas and it's not only the water that
likes to move down there because it's
nice and shady because of those trees
etc lots of water down a so then you
start to also get the animals that move
in those areas too because of the lovely
shade because of those aren't nice trees
that you get down there too and and so
they can be also a bit of food for them
lots of animals like to make their nests
in side the banks and they get all sorts
hiding up in there take SDM Bock and
then obviously the leopard the bush buck
and like we saw the other day as well
very briefly the honey badgers and so a
lot of animals do like resting up in
these drainage lines and that's why we
working a little bit alongside them
through them next to them and trying to
pick up there any signs as these two
letters that have been moving around the
area we did just pick up on some fresh
tracks of tandy so and an herby also
thinks that maybe a little bit of a sign
of Columba not fresh tracks of claw
lumber but she has been moving on
particular area so hopefully we might be
able to catch up with him I'm not
promising anything but that seems like a
good chance that we might find in this
afternoon we'll just have to keep trying
our best that seems like an amazing
sighting that you guys had with that
horn ball and the under lizard so times
view you hoping just like me that the
cats are more cooperative this afternoon
while it might be a good time for us
because generally in the mornings they
do move quite a bit more than possibly
in the afternoon like this so maybe a
little bit more relaxed you're often
found in might be on a termite mound or
you know like here next to a drainage
line where there is a termite mound as
well this is the this is the perfect
kind of situation where we need to just
stop and look and check around because
this is ideal habitat for whether the
lipids might hang around this is water
not too far from your Gallagher pan
there's also a lot of animals that are
moving around yeah from Kourou to
bushbuck and to Impala to Steinbach
duiker
and so lots of food easy water and this
is where that there has been moving nice
territorial area too so we are hearing
some Gregor wet boots just alarming up
ahead I can't hear it they're quite far
off but I can hear it obviously
sometimes it can be because we actually
walk in here so maybe it's because of
her be in front that's that's what you
need to work out and it can often be
from us but once we start hearing those
squirrels or monkeys that's when we
really know that we're in business
now Eagle spout I don't think that talam
ply lumber was seen on the dam came last
night I think it was only um Tandy but
we it's quite interesting because Tandy
was seen on the dam can at around five
o'clock so she was walking around almost
exactly the same time that the bushwalk
team was as well and also those two
young female lionesses that were walking
around from the lucuma pride now Herbie
seems to think that he found checks of
the bigger part of the pride that have
them joined up with those two youngsters
and now they've pushed off so we think
it is a complete success story within
having joined up and now they've moved
on but claw Lamba will not hundred
percent sure exactly where she is
seems Tandy is moving in this area and
we're just hoping that we can pick up
some fresh tracks of her as well as we
go along for the moment we're on
Tandy's trail and it seems to be moving
along this drainage line NARS as you can
see it here lovely drainage line with
River on vegetation next to it now
brahmic clamber can be left alone but
Andy for you know a good few days that's
quite normal and she would have been
used to that from when she was a little
cub as well because Tandy would have to
leave it in her in an area like this and
all she got hunting and then she'll
return to you know from when she was
tiny to come and you know little breast
feed have some have some milk and later
she would be coming and calling claw
hammer to go and follow her to the kills
that she's made so that's what she does
at present she leaves try llama she goes
she does whatever she needs to and then
obviously making a kill and then she'll
go and call Columba like she did the
other day when she had that Bush back on
check for Chitra Josie call Clallam body
and that was we shared that lovely
lesson with claw Lamba where she called
her other and almost some might still
that kill from her and speaking of
animals that kill die let's go to bed
yes we are very lucky to see little
animals that go for others to survive
and we got a Kingfisher here which I
guess is the brown hooded Kingfisher
it's very characteristic of the
kingfishers to keep moving their heads
left right up and down bobbing them up
and down and by so doing they are always
estimating the distance or looking at
the depth of water be going for tweed is
like a young one it's not fully grown
brown hooded Kingfisher
looks like a juvenile to me that it is
in such a position that you can see
anything that will be happening down
there for insects with the grasshoppers
or locust just watch its head going up
and down and there illustrate to
investigate how far they can see or what
they can see and also knowing what type
of a prayer it is also entrusting most
of the kingfishers got the name
Kingfisher but very few actually would
eat fish the ones that have seen
strictly eating fish are the pied
kingfishers but most and the Gherkin
fishes but most of these other
kingfishers you know the brown hooded
the mangrove kingfishers the omelet
kingfishers the madagascar kingfishers
it all good for insects it's so
interesting how they keep moving ahead
up and down such a beautiful Kingfisher
and you can set the end at the end of
the beak is not as orange as they
normally be for the adults it's got a
bit of black in it so just be there very
patiently waiting and looking
destiny thank you very much you see this
part is cute you liked his head
fantastic I agree with you destiny and I
say look how its popping his head up and
down destiny you see that and I don't
know good we also see a little bit other
bats who do that but I have seen that on
lizards if you looks at in lizards
you'll always see them also moving the
heads up and down oops it's gone and the
reason they do that well for the lizards
is to find out the depth Oh the position
of the prey and that is a very good sure
to see it move it settle down and how
exciting that's Nina hope you enjoyed
that view of the skin fish are nice
right how they got the name King fishes
yes shake here how are you and I think I
was just about you talk about you must
have got in the words out of my mouth
and when we find out how the taxonomist
mention oh you know name the birds or
name the animals check here you are
asking whether it is such a bad like
crane fish on you know and you must have
taken the words out of my mouth because
I was saying how they end up naming
these buds all these animals sometimes
it's very interesting either out of
character or they cannot convince us how
they got the nomenclature to name this
animals
well Kingfisher's and yes why not
queenfishers kingfishers when you think
of it many birds will eat fish not only
the kingfishers minibars he'll eat fish
but long time ago you know people
thought the elegance of the kingfishers
the way they hunt the fish is so sleek
and they thought was a top up there in
getting fish and they say they are the
kingfishers but i think we should also
be getting queenfishers you go to a nice
hotel and you book a hotel and you want
a big bed and they called bed you want a
king bed but it sounds useful here
in the hotel you request for a
queen-size bed I think that interesting
debate we have killed fishes
maybe we modern guides or gates of today
we should try and encourage the
oncologist we changed some of the names
or we share kingfishers and have
kingfishers how will do that I think
gonna be a very big debate I'm sure all
of us would be very debate divided
because which ones shall take the queen
and which ones shall take the king do we
look at their colors do you look at the
sizes because the junking features are
quite huge huge buds so maybe the size
of a dove and the rest of the
kingfishers are that size select the
brown for the Kingfisher so the pied
kingfishers to be small a little bit
bigger that you have the mangrove
kingfishers I think maybe me and all the
other guides and maybe all over the
world we should all agree if King
Features doesn't you know make a lot of
sense let us divide them into two and
have the big ones maybe asking fishes or
queen fishes and however in you know the
other size having the other name
otherwise say yeah it was interesting to
know or to ask which or where the
queenfishers
no idea but I don't agree with you we
should change that
I hope the question for Melinda is
kingfishers kingfishers and croppers
related that's correct
Oh cuckoo Meyer sorry cuckoo by alright
I do not know I do not know Linda I have
no idea I might look on their DNA and
find out why Linda if they are related
the cuckoo bears the bus have never
heard of the butts I've ever seen but
are they similar with our kingfishers in
size and colors and do the cuckoo bears
eat fish oh Linda maybe you can let me
know and maybe with that we can go back
and look on the DNA lineage and have an
idea you know whether they are related
it's possible but I know we have also
kingfishers I guess in Australia too and
we also have kingfishers in other parts
of the world so I'd be more than happy
if you could tell me whether the cooker
has a similar in size and color
alright Kingfisher's time let's go to
working fishes with Steve oval
thanks David we're still discussing our
little a little well I think it's a
common rough scale visit or ornate rough
scales are hard to tell it's never had
but he had that sort of characteristic
scaling on the back wonder if any of you
out there who know your lizards probably
better than me can confirm I thought
that was an awesome little sighting
first the Mongoose ferreting around
doing his thing and in there in the horn
Bell so I was talking about adaptations
of birds and obviously David's with the
Kingfisher there you'd never see
kingfish on the floor jumping around
they can't do that they feet don't allow
them to do that they're there their body
weights is actually it's a little bit
too heavy for them to to jump so they
have to fly that's why when they hit
water they fly back up again
horn bells are able to land on the floor
and run around so they've actually
really sort of taken their their feet to
different level to assist in their
feeding so whether we're the adaptation
of the beak can go and it takes a very
long time to get there to get the beak
to that sort of stage evolutionary wise
then the feet can play a role as well
you sometimes find owls running on the
floor not looking very very our like but
I really find it interesting how we can
look at all these adaptations and see
how these birds have evolved you could
never see a bee eater doing what we saw
there as well and so it allows the
hornbill is just such a much larger
variety when it comes to diet choice and
selection which is very cool I read a
book a few years ago called Darwin's
finches all about obviously Charles
Darwin and the finches that he found in
the Galapagos 150 years ago or something
like that and it was written by I
professed to professors from a
university in America it was amazing in
20 years they saw evolution happening
they saw it happening dry and wet
seasons overlapping and as soon as it
became very very dry
specialists came out you know the birds
that sort of went in the middle then the
one fincher they're really strong beak
and the one fits in a really small beak
able to feed them are very small seeds
another very strong beak able to crack
open the big hard cactus seeds those two
survived for those two types survive the
ones in the middle just disappeared so
they proved a lot of what Darwin Darwin
had come up with with evolution to be
true even though he just took some
samples a very long time ago and wrote a
book about it obviously a very very big
book that has changed the way a lot of
people think and for a long time even
during his life people thought he was an
absolute fool when a lot of stuff is
brought forward we can we can see
happening in our lifetime so that's why
you never find too many birds and with
exactly the same adaptation even for
example in the wood who poos and the
male has got along a beak than the
female so they don't directly compete
some Raptors the females bigger than the
male so that they can feed at different
sort of levels and different speeds so
it's really really interesting I love
paying attention to these sort of things
and I love having open for discussion
always always for discussion nothing is
set in stone everything out in nature
has got a way way that it works
I just love how intricate it really can
be and we're just part of the system
observing it as we go
observing it so we are on the west
eastern side right now on the famous
sandy area I thought seeing as we
couldn't find Tandy remarked to where we
normally found it well it's just the way
that the roads are leading me today and
we were on the Drakensberg on the
eastern side just having a nice little
bumble last Sunday afternoon bumble
since it's marvelous isn't it this is
the favorite one of my favorites are
Mizzou it because it's drying out nicely
you can see so much further I'm going to
stop just up here and you'll be able to
see what I mean
I mean if sense does a little a little
pan of the Rights in the left you can
just see so much further not of the
Drakensberg just of the bush thins into
the bush a month ago there are so many
leaves on the trees that you couldn't
see deep into the bush at all
you couldn't you really couldn't make
out but now you could quite easily see
cats or elephants or animals from quite
a distance even very camouflage animals
now like david has are starting to
reveal themselves just what our prince
in during the dark the dry time
especially in our winter the trees tend
to shed all their leaves and the bush is
open up more and that's why you'd be
able to see such a heart of youngsters
of yellows together from quite a
distance but far having such a wonderful
camera I can bring them so close to our
screens or to your screams that's one
advantage what do we think it's you know
it's cold is winter and all the trees
are losing their leaves as the upside
for the positive side of this particular
season and also from a distance
we are seeing some Neela Anderson that's
the male moving there and let's see what
direction he's gonna cut how big he is a
massive size of mail there because how
majestic his cutters he yellow socks
which you normally see on the males then
followed by femurs and also a different
type of one swap with him it's got a new
show we good one mr. Dale not sure why
she or he is in the wrong place with
some oxpeckers as usual on top and it's
all question of safety in numbers so
when it gets open like this the animals
of the antelopes we know that the
Predators will easily see them they'll
want to keep together
irrespective of the different species
and you notice different eating habits
in Yala's being more browsers and the
van beast big movig reza he is on the
grass and the yellows are on the leaves
on the move and the wildebeest is not
staying alone he's following them slowly
and quietly again safety numbers you
don't want to live alone illustration
something just spotted them they
underwent run in a different direction
could be sometimes only be a little bad
that just jumps like a Franklin and they
think oops there could be some danger
somewhere some of the animals that
should be doing very well
will invite like the jnanis who like me
to back up a little bit [ __ ] off you're
good I'm gonna back up a little bit and
see where they can catch up with this
beautiful antelopes and see them
foraging browsers
again it's one grazer which is very
interesting to see them going together
that way I wonder where the other
cousins or relatives of the wildebeest
all keep coming let me know keep coming
okay the good alright we have got
University or for some better location
sorry name is Nathan's question
listen your question is do these
antelopes always move in hands in
general the annales yes once the whole
you might see a single one here there
but in general most antelopes will
always move in huts in big groups it's
very unusual to see you one alone
you can get one man on its own here or
there but in general you'll always see
them moving hearts yes that's a good
question and always going Hut's or in
big groups and most who can get females
all the cows we the young ones very
unusual that you see one on its own
unless it is sick or you know it has
lost it is hard like the one van beast
we saw or the one wildebeest we saw and
that's when maybe he's tagging along
with this newest most animals will be
going together animals that we see alone
sometimes are like the elephants the
Bulls or buffalos when they get very old
you'll see them living only on bananas
in general they'll always be going has
five twenty thirty or you can get one
fully grown male and a sub adult male a
couple females middle and some
youngsters and this one is a very
classic example of social structure so
this one fully grown well that was
passed in that one you see there's a
young male in had and we got some you
know females and some youngsters ruff is
still walking and he might want to tell
us something now
now remember everybody if you were with
me yesterday morning I was also chatting
a little bit about lichen and that we
mostly find it on different branches and
so on and I was talking about a
particular foliage type like and now
this one is quite similar and it dumped
it's growing on the rocks here that
green one there and there's also that
black that is also like in there now for
anybody that doesn't know what lichen is
it's a obligatory symbiotic relationship
between an algae and a fungus and what I
mean by that term is is that these two
enter into a relationship the algae and
the fungus and with the one cannot
survive without the other so they have
to be in that kind of situation it's
it's very similar to termites with the
fungus that they use to help turn or
digest the grass and the cellulose that
they bring down to the to the fungus and
then they feed on the fungus and very
species specific as well so you'll have
particular species of algae and that
will enter into the relationship with
the fungus and the one cannot survive
without the other
and there we have it a nicely down on
the rocks we also do have some of us up
here on these on the bark itself but you
can see that is quite a bit different to
that foliage type one that we've got
down there on the rocks itself Wow and
if I actually just pop around over here
this year in the light it actually it
looks incredible yeah over there because
there's so much of it yeah and very
often it actually seems like it's part
of the rock itself yeah it is probably
edible because you know the algae is
forming the food part or the
photosynthesis and the fungus of forming
the substrate from which the algae can
grow on and there are different
organisms that do feed on this but it's
quite specialized and because it's not
making a terrible amount of food but I
know there's some birds
and frogs maybe that also eat different
ones you get different colors of lichen
you some green which is the major sort
of plant like or looking Larkin but you
also get black and orange and yellow and
all sorts of different colors and I was
chatting about it quite a bit
because you also get in the Eastern Cape
where I'm from there that's called the
old man's beard and it hangs from the
branches of trees especially the Scotia
or the bull beam trees and but always
where there's no pollution must be very
very clean air and so almost an
indicator species as I chatted about
before but I just stopped sure because
lots of granite rakia
around with this fallen down tree and
lots of locking around it as well now we
still on the tech off of Tandy and we're
just moving along slowly but surely and
as we go I'm just I'm just looking at
all the different species of grass and
trees and tricks and signs so I'll just
point out as we go and in just a couple
of different species this one this grass
here in particular is called a blue seed
grass and I always find it quite
interesting because if we're talking
about symbiotic relationships the the
blue wax bowl gets involved with the
blue seed grass nice and easy to
remember because blue export blue seed
grows also in a symbiotic relationship I
don't think that it's probably
obligatory as it is with with the Larkin
but the the the blue expo they use the
blue sea grasses nesting material and
obviously with the bird guiding from the
nesting material the little plant and
gets to have seed dispersal by the
little bird so he puts that up as nice
soft nesting material and the the grass
gets its seeds dispersed all over the
place so that's very nice this grass up
here is one of the reasons why I have
Gators these things there because those
little
seeds are the ones that are jumping into
my socks and this called a tassel three
on there's a little spike on the end and
then it's got the three tassels at the
top over there and these spike into your
socks and it becomes almost excruciating
because all those little spikes there on
the end start going into your skin and
it really does hurt so that's one of the
reasons why I have gaiters and why a lot
of the guys do wear Gators - so that's
tassel three on another one of the
grasses and as we go on here another one
- that is your natal red top very
interesting grasses lots of different
species around here very tough is next
to these little drainage lines in a
towel red top also used in quite a bit
of the flower arrangements as a softener
but not very palatable all of these
grasses so it's actually quite a sour
the type of area here probably very
acidic because we're seeing a lot of
granite this rock that is here and so
this is a lot of granite very grainy
thick minerals and very coarse if you
can see that so there's lots of them
sand this this granite makes a very
sandy acidic soil as opposed to basalt
which would make a very clay a
fine-grained kind of soil so we're just
going to continue on now think and go
look for Tandy and just marveling in the
diversity that we're walking through but
while we hit off it's hid you - Steve
don't mean to speak so softly we're
heading in this direction Rickson from
drama lodge is out and he has managed to
find tracks of Tandy with Columba well
we're thinking it's her clothes the
treehouse damn we I was originally going
and so we got sidetracked by a red
hornbill kill which was marvelous but so
we are sort of in the area trying to get
our nose to the ground and see if
there's any sort of tracks that we can
be of any assistance with it's possible
that she moved her during the day its
tracks of a male leopard heading in that
direction
don't know how fresh but we're looking
for Tandy wouldn't that be marvellous
for the afternoon it would be indeed and
driving very slowly keeping our eyes
peeled because often the tracks don't
always reveal the animal sometimes you
just see them sitting in the long grass
looking at you
don't want to drive over them those
tracks of a male effort went down into
that we had those trucks Taylor had them
this morning they went up past triage
damn took Obama roads to the West so and
we're gonna assume it's the same animal
how is everyone out there doing this
lovely Sunday afternoon send through
your one word tweet one read comment let
us all here know what's going on
relaxing working hopefully no one's
working on a Sunday oh yes we're the
ones who work on center if you call this
work
Colet it's fantastic question in in
captivity or in natural conditions quite
different because I'm a leopard they
could both live the same but females
normally get up to about 13 maybe 14
purely because they don't compete as
much as males do in males 12 is old from
male because he fights with other males
so eventually he just loses condition so
generally with with leopards and lions
the males have a little bit less life
expectancy but if you had them in
captivity they'd probably be no
difference in that purely because of the
it's all about the competition side of
things
males are obviously trying to look after
the ladies and that requires a little
bit more effort and attention it leads
to more scraps with males and invariably
two on average lower life expectancies
but that is that is what I suggest
so like tandy still probably got a
couple years in it whereas ten gaana
probably a little bit of time but you
know as I say there's an average there's
an average we can't look at an
individual and say specifically but they
are both getting quite long in the tooth
but it's great to be able to see them
and as lovely also to be able to
document the new blood coming through in
the form of shadaloo who koumori and the
beautiful little salamba really really
nice so a huge herd of elephant tracks
here which is what we actually
eventually what we've turned off sort of
West Twitter or Easter the earlier for
and they've gone sort of probably down
towards cheaper dam and then we found
that lovely hornball activity this is a
highlight of the drive so far but we're
not over yet we still have some hours to
go sorry sends up
this is a very popular area when husana
was around he'd love this little
drainage depression and so what's nice
is that we do know that Taylor had this
herd of elephant I said can you see that
the tracks in the road there since let
me just turn a little bit this way you
can you can see all those shiny bits in
the road I'm going to get off quickly so
since I might get into shot for a second
came through here sometime this
afternoon I know Taylor had them
sleeping that way that's that so if you
don't know how to tell direction of
elephant tracks that's quite easy to
tell when you're looking through the
camera there you can clearly see how
shiny it is over here very very shiny
that is the back of the tracker so they
put all the weight and sometimes when
you look I don't know if you can see
this one sense for example they're shiny
and there is the toe kick there's a
little youngster not a very big elephant
quite small and as ralpherz told you
about height shoulder height you can get
shoulder Heights by taking that some
people will measure the circumference
and do two and a half times I think but
I had a very sort of mathematical German
student years ago and we works at that
if you take the diameter of the back no
the front foot yes the circular front
foot there's the back foot it's oval you
take that diameter and you go seven
point nine times yeah Oh point nine he
was very mathematical so there's one two
three four five six seven and then we'll
do eight but then it's point nine so
there's the shoulder height of that
little youngster if it was lying down a
good meter it's very cool I did that on
a small elephant because the big
elephant I'd have to run off into the
bushes there they're enormous but so
quite easy to see the tracks coming down
the road you can see it's an it's
I heard of them youngsters in the herd
they probably come from tree house damn
from some food or from some drinking
eating as they go and it's easy to tell
the freshness because Taylor saw them
this morning they're on top of the
vehicle checks this morning so if we
find any leopard tracks on top of these
we know that it's been from early this
afternoon in the last couple of hours so
that's what you're going to be looking
for but if it was earlier and there's a
good chance the elephants have
completely annihilated whatever tracks
they might have been in the road so
let's continue on he was talking to me I
didn't get any Zara xxx dangerous having
addictions if you can't get what you're
looking for I suppose I'm really no
expert on addictions but a source a
fiery addiction and you watch the show
you're planning on coming out at all and
getting on any safaris have you been on
safaris you know it's easy to sort of
quench the first by about watching the
show and and getting involved you know I
don't think it's a bad addiction I know
people who've got addictions to to TV
and series and stuff and you can
completely caught up in that at least
here you can learn a thing or two now I
hope you can anyway I hope you can learn
a thing or two we try always try to
teach
yeah Lucis are suppose if we teach you
well I'm dad you try now do my best I'll
do my best I think the hardest thing
about teaching all of you folks back
home is not seeing your facial
expressions registering the information
that for me is one of the hardest things
I think about this job is that I look at
the camera that doesn't give me any
direct feedback when you talk to an
individual and they are not understand
your don't understand you that's all
about facial expressions isn't it do
they register what I'm seeing do they
register what I'm saying
and you can go deeper and deeper and
deeper it's quite relevant with I've
lived in quite a few countries or
traveled a few countries and it's very
relevant with foreign people when you
talk to them in English as soon as they
start if they're not very good with
English it's very easy to see by their
face when they start losing you so you
can quickly slow down and recap and
rehash what you're doing but when you
can't see the the facial expressions
back then it's hard really to know if
you're all grasping what I'm throwing
out okay it's porcupine tracks the
elephant tracks are not on the road
anymore they come through the bushes
there okay so in very close to treehouse
damn I'm gonna get off the vehicle now
I'm gonna spend some time seeing if we
can find any tracks it's truly wonderful
whoo a needle you do know how the guests
appreciate what we show them from this
before Africa wilderness for example
when we see such a majestic antelope
walking in the African wilderness and
that is a kuru for those who have never
seen this antelope it's called a kuru
and that's male because of the horns so
a steep sea is it could be so exciting
if you could know how some of the
viewers feel even without talking how
the pressure of the eyes how they
brighten the mood by seeing such what
life for such animals look at the size
of the horns of a kudu as he walks away
there
and from the villager come from the
haunts of this canoe yes and Lu says he
is very elegant quite majestic until
he's fully grown
maybe over 500 600 or so pounds in
weight and would use this horns for
keeping honey so if you could just you
know bump into a dead kudu would just
pick the haunts because they are hollow
cleaning them up and then put some honey
inside certain areas from the same
village I come from we could get the
haunts and you could make some musical
instruments for example a flute you
imagine making a flute from horn of such
an animal nothing would go to waste as
he keeps going unusual to see him going
alone they're definitely most likely is
going to join others and being browsers
they'll always be eating some leaves and
maybe he'll stop there and make sure he
gets some leaves for himself and the
chorus very interesting and anytime we
are in the bush here and we are looking
for a reliable Adam Cole we get one buck
from Kourou we'll always rush in that
direction the very shop they hear very
well because they are always in the
thickets and in the same because they
are browsers they always you know in the
thickets in the bushes so here is a very
strong sense for them and once the
either here or the photos is equally
good see some predator they go and once
we hear that all all of us cross fingers
unless they could doesn't back again
that we miss that kind of Allan Cole the
very very reliable females will not have
the horns but occasionally we have seen
some females having another issue of
small horns or miss forms or going
crooked in different directions but this
massive horns you've seen all the males
very useful even from the village have
come from once in a while we've been
seeing some
me and father which you think also over
fully grown leopard but now they are
going in a different direction from
where initially we saw them going this
way and those are trucks we also trying
to follow Steve so others we are seeing
others here at one point we thought was
for Alan a young lion and the Evoque as
we think we are in the same area or in
same drainage where they had the buffalo
kill the other day so if the violent
could be very interesting to know which
lion could be moving alone so just
waiting is it a young lion or a
fully-grown you know fully grown male
leopard and leopards also have been
known to bring down kudos for prey it's
gonna follow those trucks and see where
they gonna tick us
DJ you're asking why couldn't have come
i'll have humps on their backs like ours
I think guru's been found in semi-arid
areas
Koya is rather dry and they may have
them like camels because of maybe
stirring a bit of water and they don't
drink as much I think would be the same
concept just like the camels the hump
misto a bit of water a bit of fat in it
that's what my guests who do would be
good news will always have that hump and
my thinking of my guess is just like
camels and cameras we have always known
they don't drink as much water it's very
difficult I mean also to see qoodles
going to watering holes drink I mean my
guess is is you know the same reason
that camels how the humps they don't
drink as much water and it's very
difficult to see them drinking and more
so their kudos they'll always browse on
leaves and most of the leaves will have
lots of moisture and maybe that's how
this supplement drinking of their water
most antelopes that you find in
semi-arid areas will always do that
stain box also and Degas you really see
them drinking water klipspringers also
it's very unusual to see them drinking
water as much as the klipspringers and
the dye cars and the steam box do not
have the humps just like the water box I
mean regular kudos
all right it's going to fall off all our
trucks and listen for any island calls
sorry what Kevin's here
very good felon you're saying then the
crews are the camels of the bushveld and
I would agree with you so we can
consistently say the our commercia if
you look at them they're huge they got
the long necks and also when they walk
they just walk like cameras so we can
say the our cameras of this area pillar
I agree with you and percent we can call
them our cameras until maybe we see the
app two cameras and in that size the
animals with humps I think it's just the
kudos not other antelopes that should be
about size that will have a hump on the
back that makes a lot of good sense and
that's a great comment
alrighty we'll see where our trucks are
leading us and as again as a sage keep
our ears opened everything is rather
quiet now the wind is not moving the
buds have kept quiet no Alan Cole's
going on but any small island call this
time around could be of very much use to
all of us let's find out any ability
that ruff might have
everyone has been checking some checks
and it seems we have been following on
from tandy
and it seems like we were a little bit
far behind her she's actually now well
this tracks been found me a tree house
damn so we've just looped again and we
found some tracks of shadaloo quite
fresh
and now Rick's has also been asked and
he thinks that he's found fresher tracks
out towards Rebecca's right so we're
looping back towards Gallagher pan and
you know around this time of the evening
is almost every evening when we start to
hear alarm calls in this area so almost
one it just goes slowly through here as
we're hoping that maybe some of these
animals are gonna let us know that
there's a lipid around but I've just
also been looking at other checks as
I've been going through here and this
looks like a bush buck a bush buck that
has been walking through your nicely
direct registered there you can see the
front foot with the back foot impression
just inside of it over there and I don't
that looks like it might have sort of
laid down a little bit I'll gone on to
its haunches I'm not sure exactly what
it would have been doing here but this
is definitely from a bush buck having
sort of done something going down a
little bit onto its haunches not sure
why I don't know if it was maybe having
a little nibble on this small young
acacia or vasilia and it's now called I
don't think that it would have been
feeding on at amber T which is just over
there that's not very tasty for them
it's quite but I am obviously having
that poisonous latex on the inside and
unnerve bush buck feeding on Tom Bertie
is always possible there are some
animals that do porcupine and so on and
so yeah it's just a little bit of
checking it's a little bit quiet for the
time being but we're still moving on and
as we go through these little sections
it's always amazing because this type of
area here especially underneath these
tambuti trees and jackal berries is
where we often have a lot of evidence
of elephants having hung around here in
the shade and the tumblr trees and
Jacobi reasons in particular because
making very good shade do these trees
and also winter summer all all year
round so lots of elephant dung
underneath these but you can also notice
that even though there's a lot of
elephant dung underneath you you don't
have anything else growing and that's
not as a result of the elephants it's
mostly as a result of these Tambor teas
because the making the soil very very
acidic and then obviously quite toxic to
any plants and it's almost a void of
anything else as you can see now grass
is growing here and like I said not as a
result of the elephant's compounding it
now this interesting
droppings this time as the the Texas
we've been seeing not often that you you
know we see a lot of other done but that
that's what nice some bush back so I
think one or two little gremlins here
maybe it says the result of these damn
booties as well lots of acid around so
maybe the gremlins feeling it too with
the with the tambuti cheese so and also
lots of the marula found in this area
sometimes as a result of the elephants
having fed on marilla's and name and
then the squirrels come in afterwards
and they feed on those kernels on the
inside and then it does make it look
like it's got a little face on it so
very very rich in protein on that on
that kernel on the inside as well so
very very useful
Kathy um I would say the senses that we
use most when we're tracking at the
moment now we obviously with your head
on the ground
while your head looking down quite a bit
looking for the tracks so your site but
then you must also listening for any of
the alarm calls so I would say primarily
the two senses being site for the check
and sound for the alarms coming up
not generally too much of the smell
obviously you can smell with the sort of
popcorn II top smell that's when you're
very fresh when you behind a liquid like
this but first and foremost your site
picking up the tracks and then and then
your your hearing to to pick up the the
alarm calls ahead this when you could
dump be getting close to a lipid and if
if we had to hear any of these could on
y'all alarm calling up ahead of us then
that's when they really quickly try and
catch ahead and try and get up close to
them so that's the two things but as you
walking and you need to keep your your
real senses about you all the way
because we could have elephants breaking
punches we not want to bump into
elephants and if we if we're taking a
leopard we don't want to be you know
frightening it or getting too close it
just give us a little bit of a growl
staying with the Lions
you get quite close to Lions yeah that
little growl if you walking and you just
not and possibly even scraping a foot on
the ground that could be Buffalo and
that has picked you up and one of the
real giveaways of Buffalo is the
oxpeckers yellow Botox picker so those
that's the one that you definitely want
to hear and because you normally hear a
knock speaker and then you look just
over the bush and maybe is sleeping and
anywhere that you knew that you would
see was because of that and that noise
from those yellow bow box because that's
it's a dead giveaway that is a buffalo
nearby and often not any sound that you
hear from them
now DJ you can sometimes tell that an
animal is injured from the tracks
because they might be sort of dragging
it in a way you know I'm moving my leg
like this and you would see just
generally that potentially you've got
you know an animal that normally direct
registers so it puts this one the front
foot down the back foot in it maybe it's
slightly skew you can see you can see
almost everything from the checks I mean
in the army the guards would also be
able to tell if you're carrying
something and you know how much you were
carrying so here was lipids we could
also tell potentially a lipid that's
carrying some prey making it heavier but
without it actually dragging on the
ground
obviously drag marks on the ground it
did give away that an animal has got a
kill with it and it's shifting it
normally lion and liquid that can drag
kills and lipid with Dragons and then
tack it up a tree so if we see drag
marks obviously that's that's gonna be a
dead son that we got in there and we try
and have a look but that's also one of
the things that we need to be careful of
because a cat on a kill can also be a
little bit more aggressive towards you
because he's gonna defend that food so
you do need to be a little bit wary
around that and but you can also then
see in soft sand per se that a lipid has
spread its front legs like that and
walking with the feet actually angled
slightly more inwards and then the head
up held up high and does impressions
will go a lot deeper into the sand so
the the checks tell all and they never
lie and there are the exact evidence
we're looking for now Steve's got a
lovely bird off to him there he is
sorry it's a southern black tits I'm
gonna try a rollback here but more sins
how's it gonna roll back a little bit
more southern black tips that is very
upset with something it's just gone into
a little can you see him just gone into
a little hole as he got inside there
marvelous little southern black Church
was making a lot of noise here we got a
chin spot Betts's came to join him and
making the typical sort of alarm call
that birds get quite attracted to it's
actually it's called ching spelt with a
p a lot of esters in an h i think and it
goes you can actually get birds to come
like we did this morning lots of birds
alarm calling a lot of birders actually
do it to attract birds because they
think that there's a predator and if you
just got exactly what that bird was
doing and it brings birds in and you can
often quite get some really good sort of
you could offer to get some really good
sort of some birds responding to that
sort of noise because they all sort of
respond to potentially predator in there
and they're coming numbers and works
very very well especially for the sort
of more discreet and hidden birds did he
go inside that tree since you did went
inside that little bush never seen it
set to go into the hole like that into
that cavity
well it seems like the action with the
southern black 2-tier is gone and the
chance but betters as well has moved off
so we are continuing on track soffit
onion Colombo were around treehouse tab
which is up that way we're driving very
very slowly the no one's been on this
road in some days sins are not are going
to find ourselves it can't so you've got
lots of faith reactions move further
west but we are going to stay in the
area I suppose I think I can talk I've
got no problem talking and that took
some practice though so I don't know if
that's the easiest part but having the
information to talk about it was
probably the hardest part getting
information that I have in the head yeah
that took a very long time but I have
the ability to to learn something and
then it stays which is a very good
ability especially if I've written exams
and stuff about it so I think that you
know that the tracking elements is
something that we're still developing
it's something and I'm never gonna stop
so tracking I would like to be better
but being our chair is really not hard
actually
you know we're quite privileged to be
out here and all my friends are super
super jealous they all wish they could
do what I do and then outside and well
do it I know but you know there's people
just said I wish but then they're always
got lots of excuses about why they don't
anyway that is a female lip attract
let me see if I can get a nice look at
it
mmm it's not fresh not that fresh have a
look over here in the sunlight though
couple tracks I'm gonna jump off for
them the jump off there let's have a
look I think you can get them since it's
this male leopard it's going up and down
the boundary here we right on the fire
break that's Gary main just off there so
you can probably hear a car and you saw
me waving and there's a male leopard
that came up and it's probably gone back
down again whether it's the same male
very hard to say I thought it was a
female for a moment is what we're
looking for we'd show you our leopard as
well if we found it I think the hardest
thing is initially to get used to was
was the vehicle and not the vehicle but
the camera as I was talking before about
getting direct feedback from people as a
trade and as a guard you get you get you
get feedback directly and also one of
the really hard things is like as I'm
talking to you sometimes
Louise is talking to me here and that
always sometimes we'll see some of us
around the beginning I was like I'll be
talking and maybe I'd stutter or have
this long looking face as you tried to
register so that'll steering work off to
the right there since you tried to
register what it is that they're trying
to say I think actually one of the
hardest things about this job is is some
of the names that iterates oddly a piece
that we have to then say again and the
some some some names are rather
different
it's a beautiful little male sternbuch
he sees bizzy's scratching the floor
it's just a little toilet stop I would
say it's busy scraping over now and you
see that sorry young fella we caught you
in the middle of a number two those of
you who've never seen a Steinbach before
this is one of the smallest antelope in
the area and males have got horns
females don't very secretive little
animals aren't they beautiful and they
do very well because they've got a very
small mouth and so they can be very very
selective in their feeding sorry Lou I
didn't get that and there it goes and
they're very camouflaged and they
disappear
well marvellous he was loose it is a
gorgeous male beautiful male I want to
check something because that's not the
first vulture we've seen flying off into
the distance you're not gonna get much
of a view of it there's more than one so
we got to go to the end of this road and
then maybe have a little look in that
direction
vultures flying low to the ground well
they've come out of a tree they've seen
something and moving all in the same
direction towards chitwa you know the
radio and see what they have to say
about that first gonna continue our land
search the direction that they're flying
because it's sort of that site if it's
not on [ __ ] track
well it's not going to be very
accessible for us
yeah so male lepida flee up and down on
this sort of fire break road the fire
break that I've said before we talk
about fires and that sort of thing if if
you just can look through their sense
there's Gary Mann which is just over
there just in the clearing and it's
about what fifty meters or so from that
road until this road so this would be
used as the nice management units if a
fire for example happened to come from
from the other side of that road we'd be
able to use the road we were on right
now why it's called the fire break Road
to use it as a management unit we could
come along here and we could fight the
fire or put a fire in ourselves to save
to prevent the fire from the the other
side the road coming and jumping so we
could basically burn this section
through and when the fire comes from the
other side hits this wall of burnt grass
it will just stop
and all just die so that's the purpose
of fire brakes is for full protection
and the reason for them is to protect
property and also human life and we're
going to continue on on this road and
hopefully we're going to come up with
something special for you soon
right interesting we just throw some
Slenderman booze which is great on you
sure to see this time of the day and
first true they're looking at us and
then just took off so first of all
following the vultures could be good
luck and sometimes vultures always lead
us to something interesting the other
day when we saw with some nice starlings
he of the ground open and position of
the corral
[ __ ] the day when you had their vocals
the vultures were the first thing that
led us to that kill of the Evoque
immense or which was originally done by
the new comers we got some rice they are
a bachelor stallion get seeds on the
ground there keep moving
sometimes get insects hope it doesn't
come to the shadows over Castillo is
Charlie always very brightly colored
birds starlings in Africa I've always
hard because talents in other parts of
the world but still not as bright but
color like this one here is the bachelor
Starling it's in the long tail to move
the ground looking for insects and
sometimes as they keep walking like that
they keep disturbing the grass and some
insect will jump up if this is something
on their own on the grass that's not
moving they'll pick it up that goes
flying and land there maybe to have some
rest before knowing where to go next
most stallion most talents in Africa
always brightly colored there's only one
that I have seen or known that doesn't
have as bright colors as the Russian
starlings I'll try to get it in the book
I'll show you this way the water
Starling
most of them will have a decent colors
and the bluish in color and one of my
best for this is the golden breasted
stallion and this is one coat the
water's telling and that's the only ones
telling I think does not have the bright
colors like the rest and just tends to
hang around with a wildebeest I'll show
you here forgive you can see this nice
bad book and it's top right number one
there you see that top right that's the
water Starling well to have a bit of
yellow and so more on the mayor's who
you know during the breeding plumage
there but in general starlings do not
this particular students are not project
colored like there are silence because
if you see that one there if you come
down here far you see this one's the
blue is quite conspicuous in most of
them I'll flip the page through and see
he looks telling their number five at
the bottom see the bright color city got
and then one of the most beautiful
starlings is in number three there and
that's the violet Bucks Starling and
what is interesting is the difference of
some of these talons and this particular
one if you look carefully the male the
female are very different and it's very
easy to mix you know when you try to
identify them you might call the male
one species and call the female the
other species just because they're
different colors but that's very normal
with most of the buds but this
particular here
the violet bucks selling is one of the
most beautiful styling and when there
are almost installing in general bluish
in color this one here has the violet
she defies the colors of the earth
starlings very good
with it for Sterling's
we know how are you and always a
pleasure to hear your name colorful
Bart's you know more vulnerable to
predators I don't say yes it definitely
they are definitely they are but it just
happens they're equally clever and
they'll always know how to keep
themselves safe because when it's so
colorful is easy to be picked by
predators for example the egos you know
talk of them actually goes almost you
know hooks that will go for birds for
smaller bats or you know animals like
mongoose that will go for small bus the
more colorful you are the more cones
because you are and the more you expose
yourself to danger yes they're more I'll
say vulnerable to predators but that
doesn't mean that they're the ones that
are not vulnerable the Predators will
still also know where and how to get
them but the more bridge the colored you
are the more you expose yourself to the
enemies especially the starlings when it
gets sunlight shining on them and they
have that iridescent blue it exposes
them very easily
Kingfisher's the same like the one we
were watching before Lanica breasted
roller rally but you see some bad that
are not breaking colored like their
drone goes when this he he goes all the
birds of prey they always the first one
to come out to go and mob this egos or
hooks like Guerra via we don't need you
here they're small but of course I think
they will always know they're very easy
targets for these predators that flower
is or the Lord won't take any chances
and they don't want to be brought down
by the Predators
snakes are was to be known to go for but
especially the bus that should be the
thing or that was that you roost on the
ground either go for their chicks or go
for the eggs so what helps them a lot is
just when they take off and they fly and
they punch on top of the trees of
hardiest telling source from nurseries
in America but they're not as brightly
colored like you know the stallion sea
birds in Africa here and they're more
like the watered Starling that I showed
you there don't have those bright
feathers or bright colors especially
when the Sun shines on them
we need to keep walking we need to find
out where Tandy's where Columbus and
let's get the latest a bit from ruff now
well we we're not sort of following up
on Tandy to a Lambo anymore well you
never know we might actually pick up
with him because some we still not 100%
sure which checks we following finding a
female leopard checks and we are hitting
now towards treehouse Dam because that
big loop
Herbie sees this morning that you guys
were quite close behind it but she
obviously just avoided the the group
that was walking possibly also the
vehicle as well sometimes I do that they
just just in the thicket just near to
you but I don't really want to be seen
which is absolutely fun and leopard that
doesn't want to be seen
won't be so we're just now making our
way in the direction where it seems like
she's moved back towards treehouse them
as I say whether it should Lou or Tandy
remains to be seen but hopefully when we
get down there we might actually you
know find her that would be great but
now don't forget to send us your
questions and your comments is an
interactive Safari and we'd love for you
to be involved what is this
see ya now this is an interesting
question I'd love for you to say to me
what animal do you think has food that
and there's another big clump over there
it's quite indicative of a very specific
animal list and and if we put that a
little bit on the side just so that you
can see just different angles of it this
is a specific animal
anybody got any clues there or any idea
which animal do you think this was if we
start to break it open we can see that
this looks like just grass I would say
it doesn't seem to be any leaves of
sticks just grass shoots
so and it's got quite a particular shape
to it as well
it's quite interesting this now but you
say kudu it is not kudu and the reason
why I say that is because this looks to
be a hind gut fermenter and the reason I
say that is because we can see quite a
lot of the grass inside of this little
piece of dung here and it's quite there
you see quite big pieces and normally
with your ruminants like ooh dude with
their constant chewing and regurgitation
you don't really have big pieces like
that on the inside there so this is a
Hawn gut fermenter but which one you see
the size of it it looks quite small for
a iron gut fermenter which animals
aren't got fermenter well very classic
one is an elephant okay but I'm not
gonna say the other ones because I might
give away the answer but definitely not
a ruminant and the Kudus down is it's
almost like a mini American football
that's what they looked like I think
yeah we've got some scrub hair down and
it's quite similar to that but more of a
other of an American football shape mad
magic dragon wizard you said it was a
dragon well I'll say that if if we
didn't have dragons around yeah I don't
think that they who would look like this
because I'm pretty sure the dragons are
meat-eaters
wouldn't they be although I think they'd
likely meet well done so yeah it would
be quite crispy meat eaters I would say
dragons definitely not the G Tyrians
that could be the strangest dragon
around but yeah so not a dragon and it's
not a scrub here like that and it's not
a kudu so what else what else everybody
come on and here we can see the site way
it was Anke you are absolutely right it
is a zebra but it is a very small zebra
this was a baby zebra that has Pooja and
the trick here was I was actually hoping
that somebody who
say to me a warthog because warthog and
zebra dung looks almost identical
especially they're both hard gut
fermenters and the shape of their dung
looks identical as well especially a
young zebra but the difference between
the two wouldn't be anything on the
inside the inside would look exactly the
same but on the shape a zebra dung is
kidney shaped you see that see how this
kidney shaped as I turn it around in my
hand kidney shaped as opposed to a very
much ball shape of a warthog would be
like that okay
so almost like the half size of a zebra
is a warthog but it's identical and I
often used to trick my students with
that
well not check them but also say to them
which is it you need to look closely you
need to be careful because what is it
zebra or warthog and often used to get
it wrong so kidney shaped like that
that's a zebra and this is a young zebra
and if it's just a ball like that
then that would be warthog so that's our
very real dung lesson for the day for
the afternoon all right let's head
towards chi-ha stem I think Steve
overall might be in the area they
already let's see if he's picked up on
any of those tracks of these leopards
were looking for
we are we were about to get back to
treehouse day I'm after doing an
enormous loop and know nothing too much
to report at the moment we're still
going very slowly cinder and I are
feeling quite happy and confident with
the fact that we're selling just going
to find Andy Columba it's starting to
get a little bit cooler it's almost time
for me to put on a jacket
the last thing when you're going this
slowly you don't get too much of a wind
breeze david has really put in his
jacket but he is probably driving a bit
faster than me I suppose I am at a
snail's pace I've said I want to miss
anything and if this beautiful lepidus
is indeed moving with Columba I don't
want to miss the track of them moving
because this is the time of day where
you as you all know they would start
moving around so Ralph and Herbie are on
their way down here now and we'll
probably end up giving them a lift back
if it gets too late
hmm I haven't even seen the tracks that
Rexton was talking about so I couldn't
even show you those tracks but he
definitely saw a leopard with cupboard
tracks and if I find them I will show
them to you there's a good chance they
came to drink and then I believe they
possibly went back sort of on that side
it's a characteristic sort of behavior
when there's some meat to be had
Zhora thank you for the vote of
confidence
it is a yeah hard to find a leopard but
we've been trying all day I think you
know maybe she should just give us a
little bit of a break
don't you sandy everyone's dying to see
your daughter Audrey we are dying to see
you Columba come and play some games
with us okay well then a big loop we're
back where we were earlier elyes we're
definitely here having a little bit of a
if I go back see beautiful sand bath in
the road there just up ahead they're
having a very nice dust bath I'll go out
and show you oh sorry about the break
I'll show you what I mean it's all
around with a very long nose how far can
you see they're picking up the dust
picking it up I'm just I don't have much
of a back though yeah lots of it over
here
lots of picking up you can see where the
trunk has been moving all around here
they use their feet sometimes to sort of
loosen it up just like that and then
they'll pick it up and throw it
underneath the belly or over the back
Taylor was very lucky to find a whole
herd of them sleeping this morning I've
only ever seen one elephant at a time
lying down which was the last time I saw
that was up in the northern Kruger
they'd been a few elephant deaths due to
certain types of diseases that were
going around and I saw an elephant quite
far off and so I thought I know
elephants dead so I started walking
towards it and it stood up so yeah if
you want to if you think an elephant's
dead and you want to go investigate
maybe first throw stone nearby to see if
it responds if it doesn't respond throw
a bigger stone and if it still doesn't
respond throw an even bigger stone
because quite soundly but he stood up
it's amazing how quickly a fully grown
male elephant can jump to his feet it
wasn't quicker than me though I got out
of there very quickly but it was a very
good lesson learned
so I was talking earlier about sand sand
filtering the water and if sensor can
get in on that dam on the water hole
there you'll actually see exactly what
it is that you know the elephants are
it's a beautiful maybe we just stay
right there since a that's beautiful I
was going to show you how green and
murky the waters started to look at it
never mind that's a match me just trust
me it's very green and murky so that's
why elephants will prefer to feed on
them on more sort of filtered cleaned
water they don't have their own you know
most animals don't have the choice we
saw who was at in Ghana last week or so
drinking in the muddiest muddiest water
you've ever seen and yet animals have to
survive our chair but the elephants they
will choose the freshest water available
but I'm just going to stop speaking for
a moment because that is worth a moment
of silence
this is definitely the easiest part of
the day or the job should I say parking
looking at a sunrise or sunset we don't
have to do anything
the scenery does it all
very peaceful and very calming indeed Lu
Massey I can't agree with you more
absolutely stunning one thing I do know
as soon as that Sun disappears the
temperature's going to drop a few
degrees so I'm going to get ready soon
to put on something warm but not just
yet
and if you could hear that oxpecker that
was flying over off it flies into the
distance probably to go roost for the
night as most of the birds will and
shortly we'll be putting on a jacket but
I believe mr. Guiteau is already all
snuggled up yes he's gonna be chilly now
and I've put on my favorite purple
jacket because the temperatures have
gone down and the other day I was just
wondering like once it gets cold it's
like let me see if a term and mount has
some town where the continued there's
got some home business really really any
jacket or not don't look very clear tell
me how can I see anyone goose there on
the very top as you just get to the that
open area where there they must have
gone in oh no worries frog
thank you very much as just wondering
whether yeah right there
there's just the hole and I was just
wondering if they'll be putting on their
jackets because it's getting chilly and
the temperatures have gone down and it's
just wondering the other day once the
Sun sets it's like yeah nobody there
we'll just keep going
no worries further and I just think he
wants to certain sets
it's like the temperatures are going
down every 10 minutes we have like a
drop a drop a drop of one degree and if
that's the case that'll mean by the time
we know we are finishing it's gonna be
too cold having this touch with about H
2 degrees Fahrenheit and oh I think
every 5 minutes because the Sun Goes
Down is chilling you have one layer on
after a few more minutes and it gets a
bit chilly and then you have you know
another layer on what I really want to
see is snow like when you look at the
Drakensberg mountains and see the snow I
think in the winter that should make
more sense to me is any winter that will
have snow on the ground but I think it
gets cold here maybe sometimes even
below zero but I doubt we get snow where
we are apart from their dragons and
bunk'd mountains that you have snow on
their very top right I think during
winter there'll be more more snow than
any other time so this is the moment now
to start listening very carefully
opening our ears for any one call with
this big drop of temperatures any cut
that could have been laying down has
every reason to move around either for
your stretch or for drink or for making
plans to get some dinner and these are
the hours distiller pods a lot we have
been seeing hukum or eating goners you
note in Ghana and even Tandy anytime
after 5 o'clock all the temperatures but
cool stuff like this they'll always move
around and go to drinking points or we
just put them on the road booking we
haven't seen any other further trucks
for what is so before
Turin you're asking what's my most
favorite time to be on Safari I'm not
sure you're talking of the hours in the
morning or in the afternoon maybe all
the time of a year let's see if you took
your the time of the day Joe I would say
for me the mornings are always my best
the mornings are always my best because
what happens at night we'll always know
some of the things go wrong at night and
when we wake up in the morning the
vultures will be out there leading us
directions will get here hyenas go they
lead us to some directions and comes at
night most animals tend to slow down and
not much activity will go but when we
wake up in the morning to me everybody's
fresh and always good to go so tip for
me the mornings are my best time to be
out from safari and also I have you know
slept fresh relaxed and have every
reason to have a lot of energy to keep
my eyes open so mornings are my best
when I'm out on safari hopefully don't
lose signal here I'm going down a little
drainage
all right coming out of that area I got
to lose signal think I'm still good a
bit bumpy are you holding on [ __ ] very
good keep holding on there so yeah I
mean mornings to me to not intend to be
very good and if you look say which
month are the best for Safari I would
say to depend on where you are if you
know place like in East Africa I would
say July August are the best times
because of the migration was the best
thing but I'll tell you any time of the
year you come on Safari they'll always
be something not necessarily for
migration like here we don't get the
migration where we are but every day you
go out they'll be a bad they are they'll
be an animal doing something we saw
their walkers the other day having a
kill you know eating a buffalo we have
always seen leopards having kills so it
doesn't have to be a particular time but
if you choose to go to East Africa
always recommend July and August
alrighty keeping your eyes open with
starting some owls now flying because it
have cooled off very well
I don't know how the alleys have been
the whole day lots of trucks for Ellis
but none in sight but again because of
winter and the change of everything they
must have moved and also loose haze from
the final control she is wondering why
the alleys have gone but let's see Volvo
had so many trucks of them and I think
ruff - but you cannot tell where they
have gone maybe there could be going for
drink this time around but we know they
are there but snowing of the big needy
for food they tend to go to different
areas to make sure they sustain the big
bodies and the massive weight of food
they eat to get anything like 600 pounds
of food for fully grown elephant it's
not easy they need to move a lot bring
it down the trees a lot of grass so they
need to move a lot but we definitely
know they somewhere all right we're
gonna keep moving on and chancing
minam or are there any different words
for the seasons not really because
apparently apart from like now where we
are in South Africa where we got you
know like winter this time around and
then we'll have someone after after
after winter in East Africa where it
come from we don't have winters you
don't have summers we have just a
wonderful sunny weather all around there
and so for that reason we do not have
are any names or words four seasons in
Swahili we do not have any it's always
during the dry time when it's warm and
we say juoh
dua jua and then when it's cold we just
say be ready for cold and that's it but
like names full winter or spring or
summer we do not have any so hilly far
corner may be bumpy buff's pictures me
sorry about that
hold on all right hopefully my signals
still there
the some of this journey is only coming
our signal tend to dip and disappear
I'll be more than happy if I could see a
power spotted are this time around or
verax ago this is the time they normally
come out trying to cool stuff like that
or just meeting Tandy you know around
the corner or Tigana
or who koumori and all those helpers
could be something nice been wondering
where their vocals went after this
morning seeing the hyenas coming on that
killing hundreds Wow tens of watches to
clean all they left you behind and my
thing is they are not very far from bat
area it could be the same drainage movie
they went somewhere and they drunk them
serve lots of water and they decided to
go home because with all the killers of
the tundra pounds of meat in the eighth
I think this should be covered for the
next three or four days we are all
crossing fingers at the moment and let's
find out whether ruff is lucky or not
well it seems like there is a little bit
of good news on the radio but I'm gonna
leave the other guys to surprise you on
that I just want to show you some very
nice interesting checks along the roads
here now obviously we do have some Tire
vehicle checks moving through like this
but there's something that starts to
move through here now it looks like a
bit of a tail but on either side of this
tail there are some footprints as well
look over there there is a nice big
footprint there and you can see how this
tail is dragged continued continued and
dragged a long side of the ride now if
we look at the drag as well closely and
you know if it with reptiles and and or
a snake monitor lizard etc if they
dragging their tail you very often have
the point of the tail that goes off in
the middle or it you know sometimes it
can go off on the side yeah but what we
notice in here is there's lots of little
points on the inside of this drag could
what do you think that could be I think
it could be here so this tail had hair
on it as you can see as it's gone
through there so it's definitely not a
reptile because I don't know of any
reptiles that have got hair on their
tail now if we start to look a little
bit closer on this track you can see
it's got one two three four toes there
and possibly a little one over there
right and it's it's getting a little bit
of a v-shape if you've been listening to
my tracking stories and theories and
what kind of little Shrek is that this
is a very small one but this is of a
vervet monkey a little velvet monkey the
little perverts that hang in the trees
but also sometimes run on the grass and
drag their tail so this is also a great
one because they very often do this but
because there's a child tail drag mark
it often also confuses people because
then they start to think of all sorts of
animals that has
a tail drag but from here you can also
see a nice footprint over there as well
as over there and is very clear little
thumb that's a nice one where you can
see his thumb and also just put a little
bit of light on it just so you can see
it differently because we are getting
into that night hours just to give you a
nice impression as we got across there
as well and then onto that and that
footprint there and a little bit of a
drag mark so I'm putting the light on
because the Sun now has gone down and
we're heading a little bit back towards
camp because once the Sun does sit
obviously it's time for us as the
bushwalk team to start making our way
back towards camp and and well that's
what we starting to do never staying at
very much after or much longer after
sunset because it does get a little bit
now Anki the only reason I've called him
little pivots is because it's a vervet
so a little a little velvet a little
pivot that sits up in the tree and
watches us when we when we in our
showers or whatever so just a little bit
of a large horde exactly that's any
reason I call them little pivots because
monkeys they not only spot us as humans
and give away the little alarm calls
towards us but they are excellent to
spot all sorts of animals like leopard
and lion and the vultures are the birds
of prey
excellent indicators and they have an
excellent eyesight so you can never
sneak up on a monkey and I challenge
anybody to try and do that
they are so alert they're more little
than Impala and excellent for us to to
use whooping it's that time of the
evening it's that time of the evening
they're starting to wake up the whooping
call of a hyena that's awesome now
so we starting to make our way towards
camp it's just about the last you'll see
of us but speaking of those little
perverts I'm going to hit you on over to
a very fluffy looking man I really don't
know what to say
since I do you have any idea what to say
to what the link we just received from
Ralph
well there guys asked offering Ralph a
lift home
sure shots fired
okay well I'm sure Ralph is laughing
right now haha funny how high isn't it
yeah well we are still working around
triage damn we are hoping to find
something but so far we're finding is
his tracks the old tracks here of the
uncle homers or some leopard tracks from
this morning here in this direction
there's that time of day you can see my
layers on it's definitely warmer this is
the time of day where the lipids come
out to play don't they Suzie
so Rhodesia's big loops around switching
off and listening ways good to listen
moments of silence
okay thanks Lou
Lou says I've got very good listening
skills okay so our interesting
two tracks of lionesses of teams that
head towards and headed towards the west
possibly the two youngsters from this
morning heading to follow the rest that
on Google map right
afternoon that was them our mechanic
here is the one who spotted a lip but
this morning that we tried to follow up
on but we were not fortunate the
Leopards have been giving us the
absolute runaround Croft II my silent
retreat was fantastic was very hard but
it is very hard to sit on your bottom
for 13 hours a day meditating and going
inward and just focusing on the issues
that are pertaining to your life and
that is what you basically spend the
entire time doing dealing with you're
dealing with your own problems and the
things that make you react to life's
sort of unexpected ups and downs which
are all the time aren't they how we
react to them the technique that I was
practicing for the fourth sitting now is
all about just breathing focusing on
your on your mind and just letting go of
all the nonsense all the baggage so very
powerful very hard but this being my
fourth time was very very deep very deep
and yeah I'm feeling very happy and very
good there's still things to work on as
always you can't go to one of those
courses and think you're going to come
out enlightened you're going to learn
how to move down that direction but it
takes work and it's a very long path but
very good for the soul and good for the
for the body as well I lost weight a
little bit bit of a fast there come back
my mind is strong and where I'm
exercising with a couple of young lads
and camp you know you're gonna pick the
little young lads and say come on and
then they push me a bit harder which is
great
okay so it's not carrying on along here
Luke is one of the young lads and here's
an FC at the moment he says I'm the one
pushing but you know I'm feeling
stronger and fitter now my mind is it's
very easy to to give up on stuff though
if your mind is on the right space so
the mind is the most powerful instrument
one of the stories in there in the the
practice given was our mind is like an
enormous elephant obviously these
practices all come from sort of India
our mind is like a very very wild
elephant bull and if we do not train
that elephant it can be very destructive
but by training it very patiently and
very persistently you are able to
harness it and use it for your own
benefit so your mind once trend can be
extremely powerful but we're going to
carry on let's go over to ruff for a
final word now yeah Steve that's it's
quite pertinent what you're saying about
training the mind you know people find
different ways of that kind of silent
retreat and getting them on right well
for me I do find it a lot of the
spending time with nature whether it be
out surfing on your own or out in the
bush on your own and sometimes just
pressing the body a little bit whether
it's running or surfing fighting the
waves etc for me when your body is
exerting itself I think that's when you
you actually truly find yourself lots of
oxygen pumping through your mind and
your body physically and also working I
like that now we are as I said coming
towards the end of the day and I agree
with Dave that morning time is one of
the best times to go out on safari but I
also find this evening time when that
Sun is set already
and that dusk as it starts to settle now
especially when it's calm when there's
not too much wind and you start to have
the awakening of the night shift but it
overlaps with the day shift so you've
got and
Lake and from both sectors from both
quarters the nocturnal and the die you
know we say crepuscular but there's a
lot of animals moving around at this
time of night
hyenas start to wake up you start to
hear the jackals lions leopards are
moving around and yet you've still got
all the daytime
birds calling you start to have the
nighttime birds calling and say this is
really a mixture and it's really starts
to boil and bubble and I really enjoy
this time of the evening as well as one
of my favorite but well as I said
favorite time and also for me sitting
out on a termite mound like this it's
absolutely amazing
now minimu in general I would say that
in the morning is better to be able to
hear predators because it's it's
normally a very calm there's no wind and
it's quite and it's normally cooler so
the cold air is and the comet is the
better you can hear all that all of
those sounds it's not necessarily that
there's more things calling it's just
that you can hear it better and you know
and that makes sense because sound
travels better underground that it does
in open air and it also travels further
underwater as well because that is more
dense so when it's cooler the air is
more dense then when it's hotter warmer
in the middle of the day added with the
fact of wind
it definitely dampens calls a lot so I
would say definitely in the morning but
light afternoon like this now this term
can be good as well but I would say in
general the best time would be early
early morning and normally for me I used
to find at different water halls in
different game reserves normally between
between two and four o'clock in the
morning was for me the best time but now
the best time for us to head back to
camp is right about now
so I'm gonna say goodbye and [ __ ] to
Rafiki dies well here we are at my
favorite waterhole and there being some
habits
that a leopard has been spotted here but
now nobody can see it so we just want to
find out where it could have gone and
let's find out is okay I think we might
be lucky to see it in use and some very
good news after all these following
trucks there could be let's find out if
unlevered slowly they're always very
sneaky and it's wrong this area we think
it has been spotted Casa Vega
so let's look carefully
well it might have gone but not far from
where we are now
sorry now she is across there how lucky
after over the movement and trying to
track this leopard from yesterday
very good and luan the finder controls
is awesome and well done she looks to me
like a female because of the size I
could be wrong we may need to see it tan
or see her turn her head for us to be
able to identify who she is
we need to see the support button
emotion she is looking at something well
this is quite quite a posture not
necessarily a stroking posture but the
tail is shooter of happiness something
she can something getting it is
attention there they do not know exactly
what it is I literally get my binoculars
and have a look everybody is thinking so
because she Lucy she seems pretty young
she's a pretty young to be you know
fully grown and we're thinking could be
Tanis daughter
we don't know this could be the princess
she is pretty young by the size we just
waited to see if she's gonna turn her
head but by the size we think is a
female number one is a very young
Lepidus it's like it could be Columba
and the last time Tandy was spotted I
think by hobby hobby was telling telling
me he'd you know he did not see Tandy
with Columba so and fall I called two
different citing Tandy had been seen
alone something she's looking that
particular direction so soonerlater able
to identify who this is but looming the
front of control things could be to
lumber with the princess of Tandy
and if where Tandy was seen it's quite a
long way from here
not implying they have gone separate
ways it was just so strange
she's so young that she is moving and
the way she is moving he looks a bit
skittish there she goes she climbs up
she's too young to be on her own I'll be
surprised if they're gone separate ways
with who Steve oval saw them she
snatched some meat from the mother which
was quite unusual
I wish it was signs of trying to see a
machinist now and mum is time for me to
get out and explore the world it would
be possibly big Columba once we get to
see the sport button and the face or the
head nicely we'll definitely be able to
identify who she is but she's a young to
me a young gal she's hiding behind that
bush in Anna for one reason she moves so
you have to be on her own but it's
something she kept looking towards the
waterhole the Franklin's are going
definitely crazy because of her it'll be
interesting to see if yes I mean I mean
just like me I'm equally a little
concern to like see her I don't know
what's gonna do we might try and roll
down slowly and find out why she's alone
and it's Columba wonder why it is so far
apart from the mother or maybe the
mother Tan is not far from here
[ __ ] wonderful down a bit and see how
it's gonna come out there let's go to
Volvo assuming weights right here and
find out if she's gonna show up again
cuz being alone she looks a bit skittish
let's find out in average from Steve as
we wait to see what gives Columba she
will do
well we are still around trying to find
ourselves a spotted cat who is that I
have no idea no idea
right up in the north it's probably a
leopard that we don't see very often but
that is the reason why we check watering
holes they just pop out they pop out up
that gentleman close down for a coffee
and next thing he announces on the radio
there's a lipid that happens that
happens I spent two nights a day and a
watering hole and then some of our tea
with a couple of friends and we saw the
most amazing things wild dogs hunting
rhinos fighting elephants coming Lions
following the wild dogs we just spend
the time you have enough refreshments
and food and you want it willing to
spend some time it is unbelievable what
comes and goes as all of you who've been
watching the show and those of you who
have lots of energy and keep up to date
with the dam cam will notice the amazing
things that get produced with that the
watering holes are very very powerful
attractors as you know we all need to
drink
right now we are trying to see if we get
one of them walking in the road we will
be moving towards we're tiller watching
Hall soon as that is the favorite haunt
for a lot of our characters on evenings
like this and I have a feeling in the
next few minutes someone is going to
inform us that there's alarm calls
coming from where tiller watching all
what do you think sends sends our grease
I mean the amounts of lipid activity
around there this morning how we have
not found a cat this side of Juma I'm
completely perplexed with the wizardry
of her be out there Rex and as well he
was an absolute master when it comes to
tracking leopards everyone turning up
trumps so we are not giving up Senzo and
i and we're not giving up we feel the
luckiness in our veins it's almost time
for the spotlight but not just yet
just those last few moments of the early
evening which are marvelous
and if this wind keeps up I can assume
it might be a little bit overcast in the
morning which means that it will be nice
and warm but we're gonna keep going on
let's go back over to mr. ki Joo right
what we decided with fog is to remain
put in the same position because we all
got feelings this is Columba and this is
the princess or the daughter of Tandy
and because she looks very skittish we
do not want to get close or we don't
want to push her because we do not know
where the mother is then anytime they
are together with a mother they always
behave differently and out of respect
for these cuts we are keeping our
distance unless maybe she moves closer
to where we are we have decided to stay
put if she disappears and she goes that
should be not bad we shall you know we
shall have had a few moments with with
her but you were feeling honestly this
is Columba the princess of the queen of
jummah Tandy but who is standing Becky
absolutely I agree with you and your
question is he's too young to survive
alone I mean I think she was born in
November last year and thus be anyone
iya anything of the three or four months
of course leopards can be winned the
young ones and they can always you know
be eating meat and on the only control
bit of hunting little rabbits or loose
crab here's something like that fools of
either impalas or they can go for die
cars or young steam box but not until
about two years that's when they get
totally independent and at least age
Becky I agree with you she's just too
young to be on her own too too young and
when I first got here and we saw her
from a distance the way she was behaving
initially though she was hunting but it
was out of fear of look in the bushes
you see antelopes she had never seen
maybe seniors that are pretty huge and
should panic but without food wait and
see the mother come but you can't see
the mother
and the last setting a little Steve or
rough one of them who sue you know Tandy
and Columbo together and they had a
small road a car and at one point you
know Colombo just grubs the remaining
part of the keel and she took off with
it and I think the mother looks at our
like what what are you doing so maybe
this is all teenage character and
thinking you know she's too big she can
be on her own but out of my experience
the doctors tend to hang a lot more with
the mothers than you know the the sons
or than the boys I think it is too early
for her to be on her own - too early
which here maybe another two or three
minutes and see if he is going to pop up
if not will not push her and you leave
her alone turn are you asking what my
location we at the buffer so what the
whole we at the buffer stroke watch all
friends of ours who happened to see to
see how cool is we were here with [ __ ]
an hour and half ago we did not see
anything would not even see any sign the
only thing we saw were Tara prints you
know in the water and some this is yet
[ __ ]
oh we just saw some Tara prints and some
and the drug Thank You Lou and drama
that was in the water and getting ready
for that yeah Louie good very good
memory and that was it and it had fog we
need to move on here there no central
input and another half later Fraser was
just calling us we can see Leopard from
a distance and we come and you know this
young leopard is here and we are
honestly too young to be on her own and
well hung around here the two or three
minutes from that he we don't you know
see anything we don't see her again or
see the mother we'll just start heading
home slowly slowly but let's find out if
Steve oval has elaborate for us
nope I have not so sorry David
white from bodega that just crossed the
road there's lots of deck around and
probably spot him in a second not with
the lights of course if he stops we are
going to go into infrared please Louise
okay we go infrared you can just see
it's bottom as it departs they're much
more relaxed at night it seems it's
almost impossible to pull up next to day
care and film them like this in the day
they stand still and as soon as the
enormous lens with the eye looks at them
they cover is blown and they bolt and
there we go just like that the greatness
of the day cam melts in to the greyness
of the bush we just see the ears those
of you who are new to the show this is a
common or grade acre with at the third
or fourth the smallest and slope species
we have around and the leopard we've
been spending an entire day searching
for by the name of Tandy the leopard
Queen this is one of her favorite meals
so it amazes me how many of them we see
that's the reason why they are so many
leopards in the area not that this
afternoon's game drive would indicate
that okay we've lost the taker
Karen though they're not they can't
Steinbach are quite different Baker is a
very strange family I need to go and do
some reading up on them but they're a
very strange group of individuals is
there's a book about the size on Dakers
of Africa and their enormous genus we
only get one in the area there's two you
find out in the forests the red and the
blue deck and the blue deck have being
the smallest antelope in the world I
believe I could be wrong way
I've never seen one like a little
chihuahua so I don't think they are
related to Steinbach but I really need
to go and have a little read about that
because very similar some of the sort of
traits to them but there's there's also
quite a lot of differences and the deck
has got very obvious all they could got
very obvious slits under the eye almost
like American football players putting
that black sort of lion on the face to
help with their eyesight that is
actually a very visible pre-orbital
gland that the deck are use for very
extensive marking of territories they'll
rub that gland against branches and
leaves and whatever it is that they they
see fit to market to issue with and then
very territorial males and females and
the man's having the small horns just
like the steer mark so yes there's a lot
of similarities but they are not the
same so I'm not very well answering your
question very well I'm terribly sorry
but I do need to go and do some more
reading about Dacre
lots more reading now they don't cover
they're done
Steinbach dude I don't think that's got
anything to do with their identification
scrub here in the roads the Nocturnals
are flying out for us in our sins oh
there he goes and off you went another
reason why we have so many leopards in
the area there's an enormous amount of
scrub here Iran I've never seen this
many scrub here in my life as I have
here and how many of them get eaten
every night very hard to say Lou says
she gets frequently terrified by the
hairs around her room so whenever she
walks up the room the hair and the back
of her neck stands up and she gets
frightened by the movements of these
little bunnies um I actually found the
hares tail this morning it was very
likely eaten by a ton D and I was going
to show it to you all this morning but
then we charged off after the alarm
calls of some Carew in the distance and
I've not checked my pockets and the
fluffiest whitest tail you've ever seen
I've lost it
so terribly sorry I was going to show it
to you this morning and then I was going
to show two this evening and now I can't
so all I can say is that that hair that
Tandy or whoever court deafy was not
wearing its lucky rabbit's foot
who's a good eatin and all that was left
was a little tail the last time I saw
that but killer scrubby have only ever
really seen it once was the gentleman
who sauna I'm calling him a gentleman
our cozies he's moving about and he's
probably there is another daycare they
are just all over the place and a second
one popping behind it there they're just
a kid a kid a kid day care you're not
probably going it there we go I'm just
moving off you can see that pre-orbital
gland underneath the eye can you it's
sort of it's like dark shaded but can
you see it there it is
okay so they like to rub that against
the plants and this road is very aptly
named angry alley because some of the
number of leopard prey items are I
reckon you find out longer cuz there's
lots of hairs and lots of day care which
means should be lots of leopard
so we are hoping we are as I said
earlier we are making our way slowly
towards via Taylor watering hole because
no doubt my walking's this morning my
walking is this morning made me quite
thirsty self no doubt that the up and
down that tündi or whoever it was sure
doula was giving us have made them
rather thirsty so maybe we will find
something me I've just got a report that
there's a hyena at the dam having a
little drink that would be cool to go
and see so we are headed there give us a
few minutes and a gear change maybe find
second gear it's definitely part and
parcel of learning how to drive is being
able to go from first to second
okay well that seems like David is a
little bit colder after his leopard
encounter
yes now I got the third layer no let me
be honest fourth layer [ __ ] how many as
you got forgot a very woolly heart has
his days of course is a lot Shion are
gonna be and he got two layers I got
three and I just added one more and just
to keep warm so whatever let's do our
final conclusion wolves that was Columba
and that was the princess of the queen
of Jummah Tandy and because she looks
quite skittish as much as we are only
two vehicles around there the best bet
is to leave her alone and let her enjoy
and what we think she was looking maybe
at the hip was in the buffer stroke what
hole maybe she has never seen he was
before but the spinach was asleep or a
bush baby he's gonna jump through there
is a beautiful bush baby
he's probably gonna jump across the road
I'm not sure
oh he's going back road is a little bit
far he might land on the floor folks
that could his intention the tree across
there is a little bit far from to jump
but this could be really cool if he
jumps on the floor and then leaps off
the floor they look so funny when they
did so funny to see them do that like a
baby kangaroo you could see by his
intention that that's what he wanted to
do he suddenly realized that the road
was or the tree you wanted to get to was
a little bit far but that doesn't matter
you just jumped I mean he jumped from
about two and a half meters in the air
straight onto his feet in that problem
spring loaded what if he goes so we're
starting off with the small nocturnal
this and we're gonna move our way up the
tier how's that okay bush baby
what's next African Wildcats caracal
caracals more of a crepuscular animal
loose so there could be one around but
they're normally sort of more active
when when the other big guys aren't as
active so the day and a bit more sort of
honey badger like oh honey badger how
could that be I'm the only one at four
Taylor and I see Taylor was was ill for
a couple days but David both David and
Ralph managed to get honey badgers I am
excited to find a honey badger we're not
in the same area they were in but honey
badgers just go where they want because
they own the place Juma is their spot
they go wherever they want to leopards
lions move away honey badgers this is
their kingdom
just that something just bolted away
very likely another scrub here I think I
was talking earlier about hisana killing
a scrub here Knight wants you to call
him a gentleman our cause is on his
wonderings now it's gone down south he's
left his sort of natal area so his
cousins and and nieces and all that sort
of stuff behind he's now gone out on the
search in the big wide world for for
ladies of his own and I think that the
little chief we should probably stop
calling him something other than that
the little chief because he's going to
become a chief in his own right at some
stage he's definitely a gentleman is the
most well-mannered leopard I've ever met
so gentlemen hasanah
H a scrub here since I was youth me
wasn't it he always comes to greets
himself something that I was taught as a
young boy that when people arrive go out
and shake their hands and when ladies
into the room stand up take your hat off
open doors you know they've husana
if his lady sets on chairs you would
definitely put it back for them if if
there were doors to be open I've no
doubt he would be opening them hey Lou
do you agree yeah Lou agrees he ate that
scrub here in front of us like right
next to the car here it's such a
gentleman I do miss him terribly yzma
yeah he did he tried to to open the door
for Rebecca and and cursed around the
new staff accommodation but they they
didn't like that very much
so he went somewhere else there is
attention is going to be more more
wanted another scrub here in the
distance we're getting close to voyeur
Taylor watching hall now not far
nostril I can't help it you say they
were in a honey badger and I'm doing
backward somersaults in my seats even
though you can't see it's the look
pretty quick ones very how do you find
anything nocturnal
what's our Mongoose would be nice a
civet I don't see many of them on the
road we were checking earlier they were
enormous amounts of civets and porcupine
tracks the porcupine are out in force at
the moment but haven't seen one and the
cutest thing in the world to see is a
baby porcupine we might lose signal our
aerial just fell down I can't be blamed
that is a new bump that's been put in
for some erosion work going on and it is
the signals high Lucas are stopped but
the aerial fell down because I hit that
bump quite hard so sorry about that
folks if you did lose us from home and
apparently you didn't hmm I didn't bar
my license - I earned it fair and square
okay so here we are at the watering hole
we're gonna pull up here and I eanes
probably moved off had his drink ready
for his marathon bill I hate it we'll
have a drink in the evening and then run
a marathon probably at a try
triathlon apart from the swimming and
the bike riding I suppose they'll run
and run and run all night all night all
night all night so we're just going to
switch off here in a moment and have a
little listen see if they on any night
sounds that might come out
a beautiful spot
some insects in the background my
apologies if you heard my little tummy
Rumble there it knows it's approaching
dinnertime so they're usually quite busy
area around 4:00 it's at a watering hole
with with Nala and Impala is very quiet
the wind is still moving
so it makes it a bit tricky I suppose to
hang around in the open here if you need
to the show as well the reason why we
use spot Lance's and we're not filming
animals with spotlights but they the
eyes will reflect back and something
filament on the back of their eyes or
layer called the tepee Tom lucidum which
actually reflects back the light and the
Predators have got various sort of
characteristic coloration the the width
which they've sort of separated from
each other make it okay to identify take
some bit of practice small animals like
daycare and stim book with a very
similar sort of size and posture to them
so a leopard so they can be quite
confusing but with a bit of practice you
can get used to it
okay well we going to stay a while
longer see if we can hear anything to
mix two in the night
while seeing Bush babies is always
wonderful the night last night rather we
saw one Bush baby for 10 seconds and I
was with debilitate only 10 seconds and
I told him for Bush maybe 10 seconds is
a long time so to see one for a minute
it's even super special going back to
Colombia I think he's full of teenage
kind of behavior now because if she was
born around November last year she
should be about what eight months now
going to nine months this no way out see
her being on her own and as I said I've
spoken to Harvey one of our games Carter
to use here who told me the last two
sightings of Tandy she was alone and she
did not see her with Columbus if Columbo
was that far and the way she looked
she looked skittish she looked Hispanic
King either she was watching some two
hippos in the water hole there and she
wasn't sure of herself I'd be more than
happy safe from tomorrow for all of us
when we go out and find out how far the
mother is or she's just saying our
teenage it's time to go for a disco like
my [ __ ] children go that was the same
water hole apparently was the same water
hole light so the four children go that
was trying to maintain his feathers and
dipping in sea of going have a shower
and coming out and looking whether she
looked good to God for that
sure that's what Columbo was doing but
this river excuse me are very unusual
behavior for leopards at that age to be
on her own and that's you know why we
thought who live alone and find out how
things would be like tomorrow we have
been seeing their trucks together you
know the mother and a cub but from the
last trucks that you could say the were
fresh or the trucks that sometimes you
say was teeming trucks of all of them
and where she is now out is close to
about two plunders apart that's a long
distance for a mother in a cub I mean
and for specially for a female cub
but such a long distance well we'll see
how it will play but I still want to be
convinced most likely the mother was not
very far from there she would just maybe
laying around and trying to see if I let
you go on your own what you do do and as
I said before the other dish is not a
big chunk of meat from the mother and
she's showing sign of you know no sign
of being independent I can be on there
on my own but we have seen that
happening once in a while and then they
regroup again and they're found to be
living together well I guess had lived
from the final control says sin that
gasps it's really normal to say she has
a teenage now maybe going to her yeah
and she would just be behaving and
making the mother worry making her a
warrior who is my daughter she coming
back home he's good for disco did she go
for a night out but I think I'm looking
forward to seeing them together pretty
soon maybe tomorrow maybe the day after
not at that age when they separate or
when they become independent anything
two years or so for a female I might
understand it's much bigger a bit of
sense to me
should be capable of hunting small and
was for herself scrub hairs
smaller phones of impalas hopefully I'm
not going to lose my signal on this
drainage dip and after some time then
after about two years or so you know
turned you'll be like you know what my
daughter you're good to go
very good so I see you are still fine
you're good to go my daughter go live
your life you live your life and get
your kids zero go get your Cubs
hopefully that's what we are expecting
to see but yeah I mean at that it is too
young to be on how 10 not look for our
own Bush babies we [ __ ] for your eyes
you're looking thank you sir
force come here we have always had some
difficult quest of our box of pangolins
at night
hmm you never know the other day - honey
barges was spotted in 24 hours or less
the same area
enjoy asking the hair the same as a
bunny or a rabbit scrub hairs are
different from rabbits and bunny I think
is just like a name that have always
been used for example during Easter so
you'll get rabbits are much bigger and
the scrub here's are much smaller and
you see more sometimes during the day
rabbit and scrub hairs will always come
out at night and they got much bigger
ears smallish and tending to jump around
when they move well rabbits may walk
just like a small or an syrup that it
could be the difference between the two
all right hopefully gonna see a scrub
here for you joy and show you one show
you why they're different from rabbits
if we're lucky this is the term they
normally come out a very nocturnal
and let's find out Steve has a nocturnal
bird yes we do I have not seen one of
these in the longest of times how many
of you out there know what this is is
obviously a little owl have you seen one
before they often just hear them don't
actually see them all done Lu too easy
for you hey too easy for Louise anyone
else
quickly hashtag I know we don't have
much time left s takes a fire lab if you
know at all this is it is a small one
and quite common in the area but we
don't often see them you often hear them
you don't see them
oh that was me but um Louise is not
correct actually I did the call of a
very similar-looking hour but what's
very easy to see is that that ring that
black ring around the face can you see
it and I have not seen one of these in
some time and we've got the IR lights on
but they've got very orange eyes and a
streaky on the chest it is a beautiful
bird beautiful you don't often see them
and I want to play the call their stuff
scared away DJ no it's not it's not a
pearl spotted you can see it's got Tufts
on the top of the ears or the ear tufts
so it is not as scopz are ladies and
gentlemen those of you who thought it
was a scoffs owl I was thinking that as
well for a moment but double checking
I've made sure that it's not and I've
never seen one of these in the sabi
sands so this is a new sabi sands bird
for me and it is an absolutely beautiful
specimen with that very white face and
the black rings around in the see that
very long ear tufts it Tufts actually
there is camouflage and apparently mate
recognition as well so I'm not getting
too many comments through so I'm going
to give away the answer
project alpha you are almost hundred
percent correct
white-faced
owl if it was once called a southern
white face cop cell I am Not sure but
what a beautiful specimen indeed look at
that and it is moving its head around
trying to triangulate the sounds on the
ground and what a way to come to the end
of the Safari Labs even a safari live
evening as I said it's my first time
seeing one of these in drama
I've only seen two before in my life
there's a Arizona lady yeah the eyes do
make it look a little bit scary and but
what you kind of seeing that reflection
it's not really that's it's not exactly
before you see them but um but it's kind
of the same thing when if we shown at a
light at an animal it would reflect the
eye back and that's because that's a
pizza lucidum is absorbing as much light
as possible to enable these organisms of
these animals to see in very dark
conditions you can see how far around it
can turn its head doesn't have to move
too much
very very camouflaged I'm super happy
Sens have you seen one of these before
first time for Senza I wonder how many
of you aren't there as your first as
it's not easily seen what a marvelous
afternoon the leopards have been giving
us the runaround well done to David
finally finding a spotted cat but my
highlight indeed apart from this
beautiful owl was in France but even at
the moment the owl
the kill we saw with this southern Red
Bull Honda so those of you who are going
to be joining into the show tomorrow I'm
going to do my medicinal plant my
medicinal plant Mondays so please feel
free to join into that and see what we
discuss it has been a marvelous
afternoon from us here in the sabi sands
from david and ralph with all his
shenanigans on foot obviously Herbie in
all the cam ups if see thank you for
being so kind and gentle in my ear it's
all the comments and questions what a
beautiful evening thank you so much to
the viewers for joining us on this
interactive Sunday evening have a
beautiful day beautiful evening and we
will see you bright and early tomorrow
morning